what a way to kick off the new year the
Epstein court documents are set to be
released very soon they were supposed to
come out today I don't know what's going
on with it the latest reporting New Year
times that they will come out shortly
and numerous reports State Bill Clinton
is expected to be on the list now Aaron
Rogers says Jimmy Kimmel's probably on
the list Jimmy kiml got really mad
started uh going after Aaron Rogers
saying I have never met that guy I'm not
on any lists but it's not the list it's
not Client List it's a list of names
related to a cour a defamation court
case so the name May Donald Trump could
be in the court documents these
documents are just part of a defamation
suit where there's a bunch of people who
may be in the documents let's say
someone said shortly after I left Donald
Trump's party I you know got into a car
and looked on my phone and saw that
someone had said nasty words about me
well that's a name that could appear in
these court papers so don't get your
hopes up about several hundred people
who are going to appear on this list but
we are expected to learn the the name
names of several Associates of Jeffrey
Epstein so it is still a pretty big
story so we'll talk about that plus we
got big news ladies and gentlemen oh and
the Press doesn't like this theas Swami
announced he will not participate in the
next debate with CNN because CNN is
biased and they're really really awful
and they said nasty things about him
instead we timcast will be hosting a
town hall live event tickets are are
available with VI we're going to be
doing the timcast town hall with
presidential candidate VI
ramaswami uh at the same time that CNN
is hosting their lesser known GOP
debates uh with Nikki Haley and Ronda
santis so I I love this the media is
just absolutely pissed that m is trying
to go around them so of course they're
smearing him but he announced this
morning and uh uh we're going to be next
week in De Mo on the 10th doing a live
event on stage with v ramaswami as we uh
we talk about the current state of
affairs and there's a lot of interesting
stuff that he's uh uh uh talking about
and uh will be talking about so we're
really interested to to have that event
with him it's going to be a lot of fun
but other than that we're going to talk
about a lot of the news today uh my
friends 2024 just kicked off we already
got reports that some dude loaded up a
van with explosives and tried crashing
into a group of pedestrians so it's
getting crazy as it is numerous uh
stories have come out from people
warning hey man we should we should
really consider what's going to happen
with this election coming up because you
know a lot of people are concerned about
the election itself November I mean we
may see terrifying things this summer
with riots who knows what maybe we see
nothing honestly I have no idea but I
will tell you this while we were gone
for the break I talked to a lot of
regular people all around uh uh in very
in the Pacific Northwest particularly we
went to uh Alaska and in Chicago I got
to tell you Man Regular People for one
uh they like Trump I'm not saying
everybody does obviously the people who
don't like him but yo when I was uh
flying out of Chicago our shuttle bus
driver said that he said this thing
Swift air had brought in 140 illegal
immigrants on a private 737 and I'm like
that's got to cost hundreds of thousands
of dollars and he said they were lied to
they were told it was the Blackhawks
because and I asked him I was like is
that because you wouldn't have served
the plane if it was if you knew what it
was going was going on he's like yep so
they lie to the crew and say oh you're
going to famous hockey team's coming in
don't you guys want to go and they all
run out and then find out they just
agreed to help facilitate the
trafficking of human beings so it's it's
crazy stuff we're going to jump into all
that my friends before we get start head
over to cast brew.com timcast diell is
of course brought to you by cast
brew.com the best coffee you will ever
have you definitely want to pick up your
appalachin nights which whole bean it
looks like uh looks like we're sold out
of the whole bean but we still have
ground available rise with Roberto Jr
comes in at a close second man people
really do love our appalachin I say it's
the best at least that's what I'm told
so go to casper.com pick that up but
also head over to
timcast.net as a member you'll get
access to our exclusive uncensored show
which will be coming up tonight at 10
p.m. where you can call in and actually
talk to us and our guests as well as
join our Discord server where you can
hang out with like-minded individuals
and uh express your ideas the Discord
also has their own shows there's a
pregame show there's an after after show
you don't want to miss it and of course
it's actually the way that you will call
in to talk to us and our guests so don't
forget to also smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
it's the most important thing this show
is built pure organically we didn't do
any big paid marketing until last year
and even that is is questionable we got
big all thanks to people like you
sharing the show with people uh that you
think should watch it and I really do
appreciate it so uh joining us tonight
to talk about this and a whole lot more
is Andrew Meyer howdy Tim you want to
grab that mic this mic yep who are you
what do you do I'm a right-wing
entrepreneur I just launched the Alex
Jones video game at alexjones game.com
and it's going to be live on Steam
tomorrow so if you want to see some
leftist heads explode uh check check out
alexjones game.com uh check out him
destroying the New World Order in a
video game you will not believe what he
gets into including Epstein Island
interesting all right well thanks for
hanging out we got Phil he's hanging out
hello everybody my name is Phil leonti
lead singer ofal remains a failed
musician and uh anti-communist counter
revolutionary what's up man what's up
Happy New Year Shane Cashman writer for
scanner.com author of The inverted world
book series goost to the Civil war.com
happy to be here and I am sir.com uh
producer of IRL yeah good to see you
guys Happy New Year all right here's the
big story ladies and gentlemen of course
there are many big stories but this is
the one that's trending everybody wants
to know what's going on from The New
York Times Epstein documents naming
prominent figures expected to be
released soon the documents related to a
lawsuit involving gillain Maxwell and
Associate of the disgraced financier
Jeffrey Epstein are anticipated to
include names previously redacted uh
some some people actually say that she
may have been the Mastermind um but we
don't know we don't know Epstein appears
to be by all accounts The Mastermind but
she was more than just an associate she
was basically his second in command they
going to mention court documents are set
to be released this we know we've been
waiting a lot for it but they're
speculation as to who's going to be on
that list now multiple news reports have
said former President Bill Clinton will
be among those names to fact
conservative commentators have jumped on
now now hold on there a minute what does
that mean conservative commentators
jumped on this because it was ABC and a
bunch of other prominent mainstream
Outlets that reported it so wouldn't you
first say that several corporate news
outlets jumped on news that Bill Clinton
may be among those named and then
critics of Bill Clinton went wow look at
that I love it New York Times uh never
stop being you they say uh uh although
there's no indication that will be in
connection with allegations of
wrongdoing and Miss jefra has not
accused Clinton of any misconduct his
office said in 2019 that he had flown an
ep's private plane but had no knowledge
of Epstein's crimes and a spokesman
pointed to that statement on Tuesday uh
I'm going to go ahead and say I don't
believe you you know the statements
we've gotten from victims that are
confirmed to be victims are horrifying
and I don't believe even they say that
we may learn the names of their
housekeepers I'm like yeah lock them up
housekeepers get locked up too were if
you were a maid for Epstein while he was
bringing in young girls so that powerful
Elites could flood to a private island
to rape them and you were cleaning up
the mess you are an accomplice who aided
and abetted human traffickers and child
exploitation yeah you get locked up too
so if you're going to tell me that Bill
Clinton is flying on this plane had no
idea what's going on oh come on of all
the people they could try to claim
there's no evidence of wrongdoing you
know if if they said Bill Gates like
Bill Gates Flo his plane but had no
evidence of any wrongdoing we'd all roll
our eyes and be like okay maybe but I
doubt it with Bill Clinton's like come
on that guy we all know what that guy's
all about you think he doesn't know
what's going on
I wouldn't be surprised if it turns out
that he was facilitating it we'll see
who who who else what do you guys think
I think it's weird you know first of all
when they say the rightwing part because
rightwing for the corporate press has
become a synonym for conspiratorial it
says conservative oh since conservative
so conservative has become a synonym for
conspiratorial you know because they're
trying to give you that slant because
they don't want people to believe who
might be on the list or not but like
you're saying with the with the maids
and stuff I just think about those
reports that came out years ago about
those dental chairs or like torture type
chairs that were in these apartments of
his in like weird places and weird rooms
and who's cleaning up this place who's
not who who's not reporting all this
weird activity of these children uh so
I'm I'm looking forward to it coming out
but I'm also not going to be surprised
when people look at it and spin it to
support whatever narrative they want to
sell so they see Trump they're going to
go with the Trump angle you see Clinton
they're going go with the Clinton angle
and it's going to become like this Trump
everyone's going to be on it every name
will be attached but I I I bet Trump's
in it and the media is going to go nuts
and be like Trump listed in Epstein
documents anybody that can anyone that's
you know from the right that is on the
list is going to be the focus from the
mainstream media if they talk about it I
do think the mainstream media wants this
to you know quiet down and go away um
overall I think it's bad for the
establishment because everyone knows
that Jeffrey Epstein was was involved
with a lot of people look the guy was a
a master networker there's there's
rumors about his connections to uh
intelligence agencies the likelihood of
him using Epstein Island using the
island to get dirt on people that are in
positions of power offering them things
that are illegal and then getting you
know having video or having information
about it or whatever and using that to
not just Finance his own uh his own
lifestyle but also to use that to
influence essentially you know movers
and shakers in World politics and and
and big business um there's not an
argument there's not an argument about
whether or not that is what is going on
it's generally a consensus Gil Lan I
forgot I'm probably mispronouncing GL
gain why do we care to pronounce her
name right when I call herlan people
like wor about her pronouns you're right
just call her gan from now on I try to
pronounce just because I try to
pronounce everything right but whatever
yeah Goman is in in jail for that's it
now is a government issue um for you
know
facilitating the the trafficking of
human beings no one to no one to no one
so these things are these things have
happened there's and no matter how many
no matter how the the media decides it
wants to uh cast this or
or what narrative they want to go with
yeah these things are actually true
actually have happened and I think that
the public might be numb to it I just
got I got to say this because you know
it's like it's it's been the holiday
we've been off for a couple weeks and I
haven't had the opportunity to say Civil
War on air for a little while you it's
like just got to get that out you know
you know that Meme where the guy's like
sweating his veins popping that's what
it's like it's like so uh but no I just
want to point out because I love doing
that time travel test where I'm like
imagine you went back in time x amount
of years and then explained how X is
happening Y is happening now I just want
to also point out that imagine if you
went back to
2012 and got up on stage in front of a
whole bunch of people Super Bowl it's
Super Bowl and you went on stage and
said powerful Global Elites are involved
in child trafficking with multi with
multi-billionaires with former
presidents and politicians flying on
private islands they'd be like get this
crackpot out of here conspiracy theory
there are still a lot of people that
will say that exact thing and believe
but that's fine if because they're the
crackpots now I'm saying back then when
Alex Jones is banging on the table be
like they got planes and they're flying
these kids at this island they were like
this guy's lost his mind insane now you
I don't know if it's Civil War related
or whatever just think about how far
we've come to where you get you get an
Uber and you'll be like oh did you hear
that uh uh Global powerful political
Elite sex trafficking Rings about to
have names released the Uber driers
going to be like oh yeah I heard that
it's just it's just a ubiquitous fact yo
go back to 2012 and tell people that
sometime soon after Epstein will happen
the world will shut down Global Elites
will literally destroy the world the
world off boom and then and then like
like you're saying with epy talking
about that and it's kind of nonchalant
now anywhere I go in the world when I'm
getting in a car I like to talk about
how that person experienc Co and
lockdowns we all have a shared traumatic
fear ritual experience that is wild
crazy when you put it like that it is
wild when was the Epstein stuff exposed
in 2019 exposed or when did he uh well
no the exposure stuff happened a long
like Alex Jones was talking about this
15 years ago but uh when was it actually
that he got he was getting arrested what
year was that I don't 19 right was it 19
yeah 19 and then he uh he and that's and
that's when that's when the camera shut
off the guards fell asleep that was0
yeah you know it's just come on
yeah and they're just like yo hold on
turn everything off we cannot let this
happen at the time of him being in jail
I was trying I was reporting on a story
about a guy went to the jail for a crazy
uh drug problem he was a former cop he
went to prison I'm I'm writing about it
and uh he turns out to be the guy who
was in the prison cell with Epstein who
beat him up I never I never found a
place at that time when I was
freelancing to publish a story but I
kept going around being like this is
insane not only is that whole story in
say with the guy former cop like taking
four uh immigrants lives and burying
them on a pig farm in New York then he
got a cell phone in his jail cell no one
knows how he got it then he beat up epsi
then epien was put in that room in that
cell where he hung himself no no no no
didn't wasn't it reportedly the it was
reported that his roommate beat him up M
but then it was changed the reporting
that the roommate said no he hurt
himself he tried to kill himself he said
I didn't do anything yeah I'm pretty
sure go look up that guy forget his name
right now he's a jack dude come on I
just love it it's like they put Epstein
in a cell with this guy who's super
ripped and then and then Epstein makes
an attempt didn't Epstein like say
something like no I didn't I it's been a
while I know I forget all those the guy
was a former cop who was a murderer I
just I just love how Wild it is that
like literally no one I shouldn't say
Okay figuratively No One Believes that
Epstein took his own life but there are
these there are these corpor press
journals like he certainly did it makes
a lot of sense it's like Wikipedia said
there's a video diagram like a someone
made a video like CGI of how he would
how they claim he would have done it and
I saw this clip and I'm like it is the
stupidest thing I've ever seen because
the room's so small Epstein is I what's
what's the yoga pose called where you
like you you you sit with your legs
under you and then lay all the way back
down you know what I'm talking about so
like I don't know why I'm deferring to
Surge so you're like you sit on your
feet yeah you like Bend to the knees and
you're sitting on your and then you lay
all the way back your thighs are on your
on your calves yeah yeah yeah so right
and so like your legs are folded and
you're laying back and supposedly what
Epstein did was he laid on the bed that
way because the ceiling wasn't high
enough and then lurched forward with his
legs bent to jump off the the bed cuz
there was no actual way to hang himself
and they supposedly only had certain
type of easily terway sheets like that
they said he h wasn't he wearing a smock
or something oh come on dude the cameras
break the fall asleep and we're just
like dude I'm sorry it you know would be
really funny if Epstein's like in prison
he's like how can I make this the least
believable thing ever and like his plan
and and then the guards are like damn it
he got us he waited till they were
sleeping he broke the cameras look I
mean realistically like even if like
whether you believe he killed himself or
not kind of doesn't matter because the
reason that he killed himself is because
what was going to happen so like or the
reason he's dead whether he killed
himself or whether he was killed by the
it's not like the clintons well I mean
come on everybody knows it everyone
thinks it's Hillary um but it doesn't
but it's not like people in positions of
power in governments are are strangers
to ordering the the the killing of human
beings right if you're the president and
you order a strike they you know you'll
carry it out that is mafioso crap it's
just that it's polished up and made
acceptable if if if you go to someone
and say did you know that Barack Obama
secretly ordered the killing of American
like they like shut up you pull on the
New York Times here you go read about it
it's not a conspiracy this is in the New
York Times I mean maybe the New York
Times is lying I don't trust them I
think the same thing that you were
saying earlier when when Phil was
talking earlier I was thinking it's
amazing that now we're 2024 finally but
the people hear things like Epstein and
they know yeah there's the people
running things Bill Clinton and Bill
Gates these people that there are
probably tapes of them doing horrible
horrible things they're compromised
they're blackmailed the people in power
are these sick sick people and that
that's mainstream now that the Alex
Jones was right jar is very full and
everybody recognizes it so we're an
amazing time to be alive the fact that
this is popular Consciousness now and we
can move things in a very different
direction than has gone on for decades
well I'm really excited for uh throwing
money into the Alex Jones was right jar
as it pertains to fifth dimensional
creatures and and the chimeras and cell
phone towers and all that stuff when
that's proven true I'm going to be like
man I'm just going to empty my wall and
just just Shuffle it all in there you
know Alex Goes On The Joe Rogan show and
he's like they got multi-dimensional
beings that are you know we know the
Chim are out there we know we know
they're they've definitely made odd odd
creatures in Labs yeah but like and and
put weird things on aborted fetuses in
that that was it Philly or they
definitely do weird stuff and I think
the issue with Alex is that he does get
a lot right but I think he'll see a
story about like chimeras and then he
takes like this one small story and then
Dives so far into it and and stretches
it you know to something bigger than it
really is I also know when when you talk
about sometimes it's like there's just
so much information that's coming out at
once you got to like narrow it down and
then follow that path you know uh cuz
there there's a lot and a lot those CH
eras you can look up those the things
that they were making out of the fetuses
uh St disturbing let's let's let's P
let's jump to this story real quick here
we're going to get fun with it uh Aaron
Rogers suggests Jimmy Kimmel will be
named as one of Jeffrey Epstein's
Associates as the Jets quarterback jokes
he will definitely be popping some sort
of bottle when the list is made public
let me just pause right there for a
second guys it's not the list okay the
list is not being made public we we we
wish it is a defamation lawsuit
pertaining to Jeffrey Epstein's going on
and there are names that were redacted
from court documents but the names will
likely include a wide range of people to
expected Bill uh Clinton will be on it
maybe even Bill Gates but we don't know
for sure and in what capacity they're
being named and Donald Trump I believe
it's very it's very plausible in fact
we've already got people chatting saying
all they're going to do is they're going
to unreact the names of people like
Trump and people in the
anti-establishment so the media can
report Trump named in document and then
what what it actually might be is I was
watching the TV and I saw Donald Trump
come on and then I went wow look it's
Trump I better call Epstein and Trump's
like nothing to do with any part of the
story but his names in the court
documents which gives the corporate
press enough to lie about now Jimmy
Kimmel
responded he said uh
actually can we play this let's play
this clip bring it up bring it up foxy
or somebody back there on it up Super
Bowl 58 you'll see it the emblem put on
the screen and then bring up 57 and 56
have something to do with the Epstein
list that came out feels feels that's
supposed to be coming out soon that's
supposed to be coming out soon look this
guy's been waiting in his wine seller
I've been waiting in my wine seller for
this thing a lot of people including
Jimmy Kimmel are really hoping that
doesn't all right all right obviously a
clip from this particular program was
run on Jimmy Kimmel show uh whenever
Aaron brought up the the list and then
jimm yeah so so anyway Aaron brings up
the list and Jimmy Kimmel starts
insulting him so Aaron Rogers is like he
must be on the list he must be Terri now
Jimmy Kimmel says Dear a-hole for the
record I've not met flown with visited
or had any contact whatsoever with
Epstein nor will you find my name on any
list other than the clearly phony
nonsense that soft brained wackos like
yourself can't seem to distinguish from
reality your Reckless words put my
family in danger keep it up and we will
debate the facts further in court Jimmy
Kimmel you can go shove it let me tell
you brother when you rag on Aaron Rogers
in the exact same way you are not you do
not receive special permissions or
qualifications or protections over your
own stupid arguments you put Aaron
Rogers F uh family in danger when you
engage in the same public discourse he
does so you know what that means danger
for you and your family it's a normal
part of life grow up stop crying about
it and if you can't handle handle the
heat get out of the kitchen cuz nobody
likes you you're on TV because the
corporate press puts you there that's
about it but I tell you this you take
someone like Jimmy Kimmel take him off
his show forgettable it's it forgettable
he's the anti-comedy he's the guy I know
him from wearing black face right that's
the guy who wore a lot of black face
back in the day that's it you make a
great Point Tim saying that Jimmy puts
Aaron in the same danger that he's
accusing Aaron of putting him in it's
what these what people do I would say
that Aaron would be in more danger Steve
scalise was shot I can't remember the
last time I guess Gabby gers but the
last time a a Democrat uh politician was
shot it's the it's the leftwing wackos
that go and assassinate people Dave
Chappelle was attacked by leftwing wacko
there you go so that's another big story
that we got is uh uh we'll bring up in
just a little bit the Dave Chappelle
special the dreamer comes out and uh you
know everybody's talking about his
opening joke where he's talking about
Andy coff and Jim Carrey and said says
you know he talks about trans people and
it's going viral for this reason but
what nobody's talking about is he does a
very long segment in his special about
how a a fringe an LGBT person tried to
kill him and like that's kind of crazy
we watch the special and he's like this
guy jumped up on stage lunged for me
they said he's got a gun someone tries
to disarm it realize he was actually a
secret knife and and this guy apparently
was part of the LGBT community who was
offended at what Dave Chappelle had said
said and I'm like yo this stuff's crazy
so anyway we'll get into all that stuff
cuz we do have we do have stuff to pull
up on the Dave Chappelle thing but this
is the it's the funny thing about what
Jimmy Kimmel does Jimmy Kimmel basically
said of his friend and a friend of ours
uh Dicky Barrett he said he hoped he
would die wow so uh Dicky refused to get
the vaccine gets fired and he said he
he's friends been friends with Jimmy for
decades and uh you know he he was
praising Jimmy Kimmel but I'm like I'm
sorry dude Jimmy Kimmel said in his show
it's real simple what you do the people
who don't want to get vaccinated and
like that horse paace stuff you say get
out you don't get treatment and the
people who get vaccinated they get the
treatment and I'm like he's advocating
for hospitals kicking out dying people
because they don't they because they
don't believe in your world view because
they don't dude the hypocritic oath Do
no harm I'm wondering if that applies to
you must save somebody like would
doctors be like I'm not going to save
you no I don't have to hurt you I'm not
going to hurt you I'm not going to save
you either it's just disgusting the kind
of person that you have in the corporate
world and the corporate press but I will
say as much as social media has been bad
in a lot of ways with like Tik Tok the
algorithms and all that stuff at least
shows like this can exist and we can
call out we can exist to the extent that
we can point out how psychotic Jimmy
Kimmel is and I will tell you the good
news because I want to ask you guys this
about um your holiday but uh I go to
Christmas and Thanksgiving was similar
to this but Christmas was wild and I'm
talking with people and they're all
saying I know yep and I'm like you know
I'm getting people people being like
what do you think is going to happen in
November cuz regular people in the
suburbs are now being like I don't know
how this election could even happen I
don't know what's going to happen in
this country and I'm like I'm glad you
are aware to a certain degree that there
is something going on because you'll get
these trolls on Twitter and they'll be
like nobody cares about this stuff
regular people aren't don't care go
touch grass homie I went and touched
grass and the people were freaked out
yep they're buying gold from Costco to
the point where Costco ran was it Costco
right wow they were selling gold they
ran out people are freaking out over
this stuff but I don't know what
happened with you guys when you go home
for the holidays what do your Normie
relatives are they freaking out I going
to New Hampshire I mean not really you
know yeah you go to New Hampshire you're
going to Free State come on my my though
not really I mean the free state project
my family is is in Western Massachusetts
my sister and and her family and stuff
and while they're
not uh you know they definitely aren't
considered right-wing they're fairly
normies um there's not uh a whole lot of
attention being paid to the Democrats
and and to politics yet so I don't and
they're but they're not masking up you
know they're they're not like oh you
know make sure you wear a mask to come
to to Thanksgiving or to Christmas
dinner you know yeah I've noticed a lot
of people who are like not political
junkies or actually they're they're just
apolitical and but they're noticing all
the problems affecting their daily lives
or their jobs you know they they can't
ignore like I think they've been asked
to accept and acceptable reality and
they're just like something is really
off in this world like everything's just
off and uh I had a lot of those
conversations I think for a long time
now there's a good tweet about this I
forgot to tweeted he said that wokeness
peaked in like 2020 and now it's fading
away as people are finally less scared
to to speak up and I think what it is
people really did know something was
messed up but they were scared to speak
up because everyone's looking around
wondering who's going to be the Nar
who's going to who's going to send him
to goag now that people are starting to
feel more conf confident with the likes
of you know our cultural victories and
hard numbers and sales and and declines
and the boycotts now people are feeling
like this is the way to go I can speak
now finally and they're not scared and
they need to continue to speak right
like cuz I remember there was a very
small segment of time at at the very
beginning of lockdowns where a lot of us
maybe maybe you guys but I felt like the
woke stuff was just disappearing because
everyone was worried about like life
right well we're locking down how are we
going to survive and then it came back
in crazy that was because of George FL
right and then yeah and that catapulted
into a whole new Stratosphere of
deranged like stuff and yeah we're
there's a lot of stuff happening now
it's good but don't get too confident
like keep pushing back I got a I got a
good one for you guys cuz uh I was asked
by uh an extended family member at a
family party how do you sleep at night
knowing the things you do it was not an
insult it was just like aren't don't you
like sweat aren't you worried and I was
like I'm I'm actually the least stressed
out because of it when I I was like let
me ask you a question if you closed your
eyes and crossed a busy intersection
would you be scared you'd probably be
crapp in your pants yeah see I know
where the cars are gone cuz I looked
both ways why would I be scared I know I
know what's coming I know what's
happening I pay attention so you know if
we get news that riots are erupting in
all the major cities I I'm going to know
before you do MH so I'm actually not
worried yeah it's funny I think about
that a lot because there was a point in
time maybe a decade ago I'm I'm at that
point I'm a teacher and I knew something
was wrong obviously with the with the
college world something was but I
couldn't explain it I had have like a
set of language to describe it and then
once I had a terminology and like I'm
like breaking it down thinking about
Marxism all these things I'm like oh all
this is starting to really make sense
and at that point 10 years ago I was
definitely depressed I didn't know was
going on I couldn't get ahead and I'm
I'm getting like uh applying for
teaching jobs they say like white
straight white males can't apply like
what the heck is going on here you know
but now I know you know and there's
there's definitely like we come a long
way as a culture cuz everyone's talking
about the Chappelle one the the Ricky
dvas special is also pretty good it's
it's not as good yeah it's not as good
as Chappelle but I really like it but
it's one of the telling things in the
the Jas special is that he's saying like
hey to the audience have you guys heard
of CRT stuff and I'm like we've been
talking about that for a minute right
but it's like now it's it's gotten to
such a level in the mainstream Netflix
comedy special world it's not surprising
to hear D talk about it but it's it's
kind of interesting to hear him address
the crowd as if they' never heard of it
you know and now they're all laughing
along to his jokes these are these are
giant wins for sure he he specified that
in his I think he actually called it
critical race Theory nice wow that's
good he talks he talks he talks about a
lot of stuff good no it's really good
Sam
Harris is
like so broken and he's a husk and it's
so well past the point of Salvage like
we are at the point now we're at this
this this this inflection point happened
I think last year or two years ago where
woke stuff really started becoming heavy
cringe we saw the budlight boycott we
saw the target
boycotts Sam Harris tried playing
playing this like oh no I'm going to
stick with the establishment machine on
this one and he's he's doubling tripling
quadrupling down every time he just
doubles down it's going to be like 2026
everyone in this country is going to be
totally off all the corporate press BS
and Sam's gonna be like no no and
everyone's gonna be like dude you go go
be a Herm he's gonna have a big long
beard and be like just meditate more he
just sacrificed all of his Integrity in
V like it's it's fascinating to see but
I I bring them up cuz it's a good
example of regular people who you know
you know they know mhm but were so
concerned about being
ostracized actually let me pull up this
meme a lot people are very concerned
with being ostracized that was that was
that was the main carrot yeah no one
wants to be called a bad word yeah I
mean I don't care well I mean but a lot
of people do by the time that I mean by
the time that had happened I had already
been on the outs with the the polite
Society for you know since like
2013 was the first time that I kind of
crossed the line you know in 2000 like I
have said all kinds of unapproved thing
so I was on I've been on the outs like I
was if if I was canceled because I don't
think that you can be canceled unless
you allow yourself to be canceled until
you start behaving like you've been
canceled but if I was canceled the first
time it was in like
2012 or 13 before they were calling it
cancel you know you know so it's like
and that and my entire career or at
least half of my career in the music
industry was pushing back against the
music industry that was getting more and
more and more progressives check out
this meme yep it's a comic and the guy
says I have strong opinions the other
guy says are they based on reality and
he goes they are based upon how I feel
in my heart and then his heart says I'm
terrified that if I research and form
opinions based on reality a wedge will
be driven between me and my community
and I will lose my friends and family
yeah this not my heart I'm wondering
like who who's this this extra fabulous
guy is not some right-winger or anything
like that these Comics are just like
Reddit Comics that were there for like a
decade but this sentiment is not is not
what people on our side of this culture
War experience because we're literally
just speaking our minds and starting the
political fights it is the woke and the
default liberals who are living in that
reality and we know it one of the the
thing that's super important that we
need to do and and I see a lot of the I
see problems arising on the right now
with a lot of people that are that are
Christians and a lot of religious people
the way that we win is by bringing the
Democrats back to their senses and get
them making Democrats normal liberals
that that you know 205 years ago people
like Tim would have been or considered
themselves Democrats get those people to
realize that they have been lied to by
the progressives that the whole uh
Progressive project that has been been
the standard narrative essentially for
the past 10 to 15 years is not built on
the Civil Rights Movement the way that
they say it is it is a totally different
philosophy a totally different way of
understanding the world a different I
mean even a different epistemology a
different way of knowing what they know
let's jump to the story from Fox News
the ramas Swami blasts CNN debate over
exclusion says only establishment
insiders will be on stage r Swami and
former president Trump have announced
their own town hall events I wonder if
the Fox News is framing it this way
because they're doing their own town
hall I think they're doing a town hall
with Trump so on the 10th of January
timcast will be hosting a town hall
event I don't know if we can call it
it's a live stage event with a live
audience with aake and uh we're still
we're we're we're cramming this thing
together basically what happens is we
were planning on being an Iowa for the
caucus on the 15th doing a special show
it's a Monday so
it's I don't know why I work so much man
I'm I'm out of my mind it's expensive
it's extremely difficult but we do it
for you so become a member at
timcast.net
to talking to VI who's been on the show
a couple times and uh ultimately we were
like we could we could come longer
and do something uh for from the 10th to
the 15th so you know what we ended up
deciding to do is our own live event
we're lucky we were able to get vake and
we will be in Iowa with f on stage
tickets are are being sold I think they
may be up now just thing's been rushed
together super quick it's probably going
to sell out super quick there only
there's there's a very small number of
tickets available and we're going to do
our own version because I'm thinking to
myself screw CNN screw their
establishment
insiders we're going to do our event
we're going to do it and so uh uh you
know here's here's why I bring this up
for one we want we definitely want to
announce that we're doing this it's big
news V saying screw off but in the
previous segment we were talking about
how the media frames everything take
take a look at this article from The New
York Times oh I love to be included
thank you New York Times for writing
about me thank you New York Times for
writing about right-wing commentator
Timol VI said he would instead do a live
show with the right-wing commentator Tim
pool on January 10th the night of the
debate I love that Fox News said the
will participate in his own town hall
event next week well okay maybe they
mean his own as in he's the sole guy on
the show fine we're basically doing the
show live on stage I believe Luke and uh
Sheamus will be with us as well but uh
you see how the media plays this game
Nikki Haley and Ronda santis are the
establishment choices and I think this
is why Donald Trump doesn't want to be
on those stages he he knows they're
going to set up these debates in a way
to prop up GOP and and political
insiders so surpris surprise same thing
for v v actually announced he wasn't
going to do it before CNN even announced
who was qualified so I think it's funny
that they say he blast CNN over
exclusion I think we actually have uh
let me pull up VI's tweet and uh here we
go here's the official announcement from
VI and I'll break down exactly what he
said the r Swami tweets forget CNN's
fake Iowa debate on January 10th which
will be the most boring in modern
history I gota
agree I look with Chris Christie we
laugh with v we sheer with vake Ron and
Nikki you get an interesting
establishment versus anti-establishment
dynamic dynamic with just the two of
them they're going to they're going to
be like well Nikki I agree with
everything you just said and then it's
going to be like the Futurama joke where
do you guys remember this one uh uh was
it the two clones and he's like I think
your tax proposal goes too far well I
think your tax proposal doesn't go too
far enough it's just so boring but
anyway he says we'll do that show with
Tim K and said we won't hold back here's
the the backstory and CN Shenanigans
December 13th CNN disgracefully cut
short its own Iowa town hall with me
after I correctly pointed out
uncomfortable truths about January 6
which CNN instantly dismissed as
conspiracy theories December 14th CNN
then threatened my campaign on the phone
with a cease and assist and had YouTube
black uh black out the town hall after
it got 200,000 plus views on YouTube in
a matter of hours yet Nikki Haley Cen in
town hall was still about for six months
6 68k total views sad H later on the
14th CNN notified my campaign that
multiple qualifying polls which the RNC
used for each of the RNC debates
mysteriously wouldn't count for CNN's
fake debate in iow on the 10th CNN's
media uh uh CNN senior media reporter
Oliver Darcy wrote a newsletter that
castigated my his own network for
allowing me to infect the public with
his conspiracy campaign Oliver Darcy you
are an evil person I hope you know this
because I've I've I've known Oliver
Darcy for a long time I have I have met
him in person on numerous occasions we
know many of the same people but this is
the Oliver is an example of of malicious
evil malicious evil cuz I will tell you
uh VI is actually playing nice when he
says January 6 looks like an inside job
the fact is January 6 was an inside job
that is a fact that is not in dispute
the only reason the media is pretending
there's a dispute is because they're
lying to you case in point Capitol
police officers escorted the shaman
through the building to help him locate
the Senate chambers and then open the
doors for him that does not mean that
Joe and Nancy py teamed up and colluded
it means that Capital police officers
who work for the government and our law
enforcement facilitated many of the J
Sixers Misadventures I am not talking
about Riders I am talking about the
capital police who took selfies with
people got in trouble for it that's what
an inside job is if a bank is being
robbed and it turns out one security
guard open the door to let the robbers
in we call that an inside job so when
Oliver Darcy comes out and says it was a
conspiracy theory he is lying to you
intentionally because he knows
everything I just said he is an evil
person anyway I digress commentator van
Jones said he was literally shaking when
he heard V speak and my rhetoric is one
step away from Nazi propaganda scen in
Anchor Anderson Cooper said I delivered
a soliloquy of conspiracy theories
that's just absolutely false and not
true the actually nailed everything
perfectly and was very light actually C
and anchor Pamela Brown said uh and
chief investigative correspondent said v
as a history of pedaling disinformation
they're lying anchor Caitlyn Collin said
I use reasonable tone to sell Sinister
lies to people who aren't paying close
attention and might think what he is
saying maybe is legitimate CNN's token
conservative commentator Alysa far
Griffin said my rhetoric is damaging to
the country so that's what VI put out
this morning announcing that he will be
on the timcast live Town Hall instead
and uh look it's a crazy world but we
see through it and every day we more and
more people are waking up to what CNN
does
the greatest example of this is when
Caitlyn Collins says he uses a
reasonable tone to sell Sinister lies to
people who aren't paying close attention
it's fascinating that's literally what
Caitlyn Collins is doing if you are
watching CNN you're literally not paying
attention if you are reading Twitter you
are more you're paying more attention so
it's varying degrees watching CNN is the
opposite of paying attention it would be
like a dude who's selling uh balance
bands and getting medical advice from
him and he's like don't listen to the
doctors man buy my rubber bands they
protect you from from illness you're
like yeah wow could you imagine people
who didn't know the truth that's right
that's what CNN is CNN is like those
guys at the mall that would you know
those Balan things they would sell no
there's a magic trick you can do uh
magicians do this to uh I love this
let's let's let's jump in so let's say a
magician wants to uh uh uh preempt their
trick like create an idea they'll say
something like this is a magic wand
right and I can prove it watch this hold
your arms out put your feet together and
hold your arms out they'll then push
down on your arm and you'll fall over of
course he'll then say now this magic
wand it's got magic powers watch hold
out your hands he'll put the wand in
your hand and then he'll pull down but
this time no matter how hard he pulls
down you won't fall over it's called the
center of gravity illusion what you do
is the first time you you pull down you
pull away you down and to the right at a
slight slight angle the second time down
and in at a slight angle one topples one
doesn't when they're holding the magic
wand you're like see that proves them
they go wow it's magic it granted you
magic powers so what happens is these
guys start selling these these
wristbands claiming they improve your
balance and they do a literal magic
trick to trick people anyway I tell you
that because that's what CNN does
they're they're lying to your face
Oliver Darcy you're a scumbag and he's
him and Caitlin Collins and Caitlin
Collins she worked for the caller she
knows what she's doing these people are
malicious evil
they know they're lying to you for
profit power and money they're just bad
people and they're they're claiming
they're they're they're the the real the
real ones imagine finding a guy in an
alley with a bunch of syringes and he's
like I'm a doctor trust me don't trust
your doctor you'd be like wow this guy
knows the truth that's CNN it's so funny
to me listen you call Oliver Darcy an
evil person he's the guy that got Alex
Jones kicked off Twitter just because
Alex was mean to him in Congress look at
those let's clarify did Oliver Darcy get
Alex Jones kicked off or did Alex Jones
get kicked off because of what he said
about Oliver
Darcy I think Oliver Darcy was going
around complaining like actively going
and making reports and doing things like
that but if we don't know we don't know
Oliver helped with getting rid of ads
for Infowars and then Alex right like
kind of like you know called him out and
then the video circulated then Twitter
saw that as some kind of the the reason
why I make this distinction is I think
it's more likely that all the big tech
companies colluded with each other to
remove Alex and that was the excuse
Twitter was looking for to make it
happen not if if we say Oliver Darcy did
it first of all if he didn't do it I
don't want to say he did but more
importantly I think it's it's it's
substantially more important to point
out that big Tech colluded all at the
same time to remove Alex Jones Twitter
was I think the last and it was because
they didn't have a a strong enough
reason to justify it so as soon as they
saw this video they went get him yeah so
it it's it's scarier and more um
devastating when you realize massive
multinational corporations were
conspiring as opposed to some guy we
don't like sending a email you know what
I mean I get it I just think it's it's
hilarious that we're here talking about
Oliver Darion for for what for me is a
bit like uh you know Alex Jones day
because tomorrow he's going to be his
video game Alex Jones game is going to
be on Steam so is it it's it's out
already though isn't it yeah but it's
it's going to be on Steam for the first
time tomorrow steam says it's all good
to go they had no problem with it thank
God and like and the video game is him
like fighting zombies and demons and
stuff right well he's on Epstein Island
there's a character called the
rapist uh he looks very suspiciously
like someone you might know there's a
there's a character called the Wicked
Witch of the West Wing uh you know
that's good are there not gay frogs
there are definitely gay frogs in the
video game gay frogs anyway um yeah but
uh so that's what's going to be
happening I don't know what else there
is to say about this this big thing
we're doing I mean we just kind of got a
whole segment about out of the
announcement that we'll be doing this
town hall uh with the but uh it's going
to be a blast we're going to be in Iowa
all uh Wednesday Thursday Friday and
then the last show we're doing Monday
you know I I just want to point out to
everybody it is Bonkers degrees of
difficulty to do stuff like this cuz uh
that means Monday night at uh like 11:00
p.m. central we have to get on on a jet
and fly back to DC and then I got to
wake up in the morning for the morning
show so it's just and we're we're
probably going to do this several times
throughout the year because this is the
year to do it man 2024 baby the
primaries are going to be hot big deal
I'm just really C serous what happens
with like look Haley and DeSantis are
both pulling at like 10% and it's really
sad for DeSantis that he's there was a
there was a point where DeSantis was the
uh uh betting Market favorite which is
which is wild yeah and now he's beneath
Nikki Haley this is typical of of races
though I mean I can't remember the last
time uh a presidential candidate got in
and a year in change before the election
was the
you know was leading unless they were
the incumbent you know look at look at
Barack Obama when he first came in it
took until it took a while before he
took Le I'm just going to I'm going to
I'm going to go look let me just say
something everybody I get a lot of
people they say Tim you're so mean to
people sometimes that uh they w't want
to come on your show and I'm like the
people I'm mean to I don't care if they
come on my show okay anybody I call evil
and like a scumbag you know I'm going to
call them that because that's how I feel
and if that means they don't want to
come on my show fine could you imagine
if I was like better not call that evil
prick a scumbag because then I won't be
able to bring him on my show for
internet points sorry not interested but
let me just tell you I'm just going to
I'm just going to say all this stuff
which I probably shouldn't say
considering but I'm going to say it
anyway someone asked why don't we get a
debate with like RFK Jr he won't do it
RFK Jr won't do it and we've we've asked
several times okay you I'll tell you
this if I if my team reaches out to you
and says would you be interested in any
one of these and they say no I got no
problem saying they will not do it okay
and there are people that like yeah but
if you put them on blast for this then
you know they're never going to want to
come on your show don't care if RFK Jr
doesn't want to come on the show he
doesn't have to he doesn't owe me any
favors but if we if we Pro if we give
the potential for high-profile debates
that no one else can do or high-profile
conversations that no one else can do
and these people refuse to do it then
I'm going to point out they won't do it
they want the safety blanket that is CNN
and I'm not not exaggerating I like
Marian Williamson a lot but she won't do
it either it was hard enough to get her
on the show I like her I think she's a
good person I think she's wrong about a
lot of things I think we informed her of
things she wasn't aware of and Marian
Williamson doesn't want to do outside
debates because she is scared and RFK Jr
is scared they are terrified that if
they sit down on a show like this we're
going to say Epstein list who's on it
and they're going to go uhoh if I did
CNN they'd ask me really boring and easy
questions go for it I can't wait for the
day that CNN finally closes its doors
because we get more in the key demo than
they do and then when you want to have
the debate it's going to have to be with
Steven Crowder Patrick B David Joe Rogan
Tucker Carlson or Tim cast because
sooner or later that's going to be the
game and only people like VI ramaswami
and Donald Trump because he goes on
these shows too are going to be the ones
who can make it in politics but for the
time being when someone says why don't
you get RFK we've asked him a million
times he's scared okay I'm not trying to
be a dick but we've been told like look
you know we can't do it with respect to
Mar Williamson she told us explicitly
like these debates on cable TV are like
we know what they're going to ask and a
show like
this you don't you don't even know I'm
like what do we do on this show we pull
the top trending news stories and we
will talk about them what's the big
story right now the Epstein list what
else V is saying he's not going to
debate what we got next Dave Chappelle
special if you cannot talk about the top
trending news you should not be in
politics go cry go run home to your mama
because she's going to she'll she'll
comfort you while you cry and say the
man asks me a hard question have fun
what is Aleppo what is Aleppo this is
what this is what they're scared of but
you know the Aleppo question is
perfectly in line with corporate
questions and when when Johnson couldn't
answer that or even patter effectively
well that said a lot about his ability
to to to navigate the corporate press
but I got to tell you man when people
say things like these debates should be
hosted by like Joe or Tucker Carlson and
I'm like they absolutely should and
there's a reason why they won't do it a
lot of this stuff seems like there is
still
residual or or a residual effect from
the media being the reliable sources and
I don't think the politicians that or
people that are hoping to to be in
positions of power have caught up to the
fact that there are the portion of the
population that no longer believe the
official narrative specifically because
of Co I mean most people agree that the
average person didn't really need the co
shot there are groups of people that you
know some people don't think any any Co
shot was good some people are like well
you know if you were old or if you were
you know if you had a compromised immune
system then it made sense and fair
enough fine there's room to disagree I
don't care but the point is because of
the inconsistencies because of the
moving goalpost because of the changing
narrative over from from the from the
media and from the government throughout
the whole thing I think that the people
in the US are far more open to
non-official narratives and I think that
the the fact that politicians won't come
to places like this don't want to go to
places like Joe Rogan blah blah blah I
think that's because they're not they
haven't you know assimilated or or
internalized the idea that these places
are important now because the
establishment has hurt their credibility
think about the structure of these
debates on CNN versus what VI wants to
do the structure of these debates on CNN
is
uh Governor Des santis with immigration
happening in this country is a great
crisis can you tell us why it is that
you have sent migrants to places like
marus Vineyard well it's a great
question and I think immigration is a
very important issue now my my
Administration in Florida we have the
best record when it comes to schools in
our schools 5% blah blah blah thank you
for your question and then you're like
that was 30 seconds and I have no idea
what was said now imagine when uh uh you
come on a show like this there was a
point where people brought up I remember
specific example that Marian Williamson
didn't answer a question outright and I
just said I kept asking it and then it's
just like you have to answer it cuz like
a conversation can't it's not just that
it's like I asked you a question dude
you didn't answer like I got I'm going
to have to say yes but I asked you this
like these kind of shows demand a higher
quality of politician so at least that's
capable of actually interacting with the
person in front of them and V wants to
do that V wants to go on the show where
no matter what question you have for him
he's going to answer it yes and now here
here here's the best well I should say
that that is that is the best part about
and probably why someone like VI is
doing so well their outright willingness
just to say throw me in the frying pan
and I and I'll succeed there's a great
book called amusing ourselves to death
and it talks about how the medium
completely shapes everything where we
used to be a society that reads and then
we became a society that watches
television now we're becoming a society
that watches podcasts and so in this new
frontier if Trump weren't in the race
vivec ramaswami would be ahead by 20
points himself because he's willing to
go on Tim cast he's willing to go on
Patrick P David he's willing to go on
Alex Jones and actually have fully
formed conversations and people see the
authenticity and they see the level of
competence you're not going to get that
out of these establishment shills
because
they they're only memorizing 25c talking
points they're not real all they care
about is making a dollar I want to
stress this point anyone who tells you
that VI is wrong about January 6 being
an inside job is lying to you okay if
you if you don't believe me maybe it's
the first time you've ever heard this
maybe a friend said hey you should
listen to this podcast and you turned it
on and you went that's so crazy it
wasn't an inside job just Google Google
Q Shaman escort watch the video yourself
and then tell me since since when is it
not an inside job when law enforcement
facilitating security of the building
assist the people they then later arrest
okay like they they open the door for
these people take selfies with them they
also work in the building for the
government that's what inside job
means that that's it when VI says this
the woman on TV she goes where's your
evidence that the that the Biden
Administration blah blah well hold on
who said anything about that this is the
game they play I'll say something like
January 6 was an inside job oh yeah
what's your proof that Joe Biden
orchestrated January 6 I never said Joe
Biden orchestrated January 6 that was an
inside job they create a fake data point
I've made this example over and over
again about fact Checkers they'll say
you'll watch a video of Donald Trump uh
you know high-fiving Shinzo Abbe and
then a fact check did did Donald Trump
high five Shinzo AB dot dot dot on
Sunday and then it'll say false it'll
give you this big long screed about how
Donald Trump did not high- five shenzo
AB the light shenzo AB mind you and then
at the very bottom will say well he did
high five them he did not high five them
on Sunday they add that fake information
to it did Shane Cashman appear on Tim
cast IRL to discuss the election Dave
Chappelle taxes and other important
American
issues on Monday false he did not it was
Tuesday yeah that's the game they're
playing and so what happens is your
friends and family your liberal aunt and
uncle and cousins watch CNN and CNN is
doing that all day when J when V says
January 6 looks like an inside job then
they come out and they go and VI is
claiming the Biden Administration
orchestrated January 6 all these people
are out of their minds he never said
that I think their magic trick is
starting to fail though like were you
saying earlier that they Chang the
center of gravity they're now calling
you right-wing Tim pool and you're
laughing about it you know they're going
to have to start saying things like
extremist militia leader Tim P they're
going to have to keep they're going to
have to keep saying things that are
insane because the what they're trying
to push nowadays it's mainstream
mainstream ABC to promote a boy chopping
his genitals off now he's a girl the
things that they're trying to push are
so far out of the main that they've had
to change the center of gravity well
let's talk about this story
from cnr.com Dave Chappelle Compares Jim
Carrey role to trans people this is
taking the Internet by storm Dave
Chappelle's new comedy special the
dreamer is out and the first joke he
makes in his special it's a master class
in comedy I think how long is it like 7
minutes long it's a good it's a good
buildup he tells this long story it it's
an emotional roller coaster my dad died
and I'm I'm he says I'm I'm I'm in
distress nor McDonald and Andy Kaufman
are in it nor McDonald calls him on the
phone and says would you like to meet
Jim Carrey and Dave says he's my I'm I'm
such a big fan he then goes on to praise
Jim Carrey as like a natural talent that
you just can't learn he gives this
really long story about how he finally
met Jim Carrey Jim Carrey is is is
method acting as Andy Kaufman so when he
shows up they're like don't call him Jim
call him Andy and he's like what and
he's like this is so weird and he's like
in hindsight how amazing was it
to get to witness this artist in one of
his most powerful roles you know by the
time I got to admit I was disappointed
and then after this big long story and
he's like so there I am I know that's
Jim Carrey but they're making me say
Andy and the reason I tell you this
story that's how trans people make me
feel like that whole buildup was for
that kind bang like a shotgun blast now
here's why this is important Dave
Chappelle immediately then afterwards in
insults handicapped people conservatives
Madison cauthorne
specifically he makes specifically
specifically Madison cauthorne he goes
off on Madison car it is brutal he make
a joke too while he's at it the
whole thing is mocking him for being
handicapped man he says he lost uh he
lost his re-election he lost his seat he
lost his seat as a handic he ran a bad
race ran and the crowd is losing it and
then he goes on to claim that the only
reason anyone would invite Madison to an
orgy and then he imitates a paraplegic
getting gangang I was wondering if
you're going to bring that up but the
reason I bring this up is Dave Chappelle
did not single out the trans Community
he literally made fun of anybody he
could and back to back because he's not
actually trying to insult trans people
he's making jokes he then makes jokes
about handicapped people he makes jokes
about Republicans even he makes jokes
about Asians and then the same joke
makes makes a joke about black people
he's just ribbing on everybody and
everyone's loving it here's why I say
all of it is important Dave Chappelle is
the goat okay they call him the goat the
greatest of all time when he releases a
Netflix comedy special which is number
one by the way right now it's hilarious
and he says this is how I feel and I can
joke about these things he is telling
regular people it is now okay for you to
joke as well about conservatives about
the handicapped about Asians about black
people about trans people we just have
jokes yes he's basically setting that
Line in the Sand so now you know over
the past several years you've had people
who are scared to do comedy Jerry
Seinfeld talked about all those years
ago college campuses are insane all
these people getting canceled Dave
Chappelle comes out and says you can't
cancel me they tried they couldn't they
couldn't do it $20 million for a comedy
special and the first joke he does was
about trans people and he follows It Up
by saying I'm not going to if you if you
thought you were going to come to this
show and to hear me joke about these
people you thought wrong I'm not going
to joke about these people it was not
worth it maybe three or four times it
does an impression of a handicapp person
who came to a show to hear trans jokes
and then is disappointed that he's
hearing handicap jokes but then is then
later happy when he hears handicap or or
trans jokes again it's it's brilliant
and like I think his audience and a lot
of audiences comans it was DC and it's a
barometer of the culture right like
that's the the audience was just in love
right and there's that that feels really
good to see that when the whole crowd
erupts cheers when he finishes the first
joke about Andy Kaufman I was like wow
dude a DC liberal audience is cheering
and clapping for what he just said about
how he feels when he's told he has to
act like someone is someone else and
then when he mentions madis and coor and
someone goes in the audience like
clearly not a conservative not a fan but
there are a lot of people now that
saying wokeness is dead it's been dying
out it was never popular to begin with
people were just too afraid afid of
cancel culture when someone like Dave
Chappelle stands up and says dude I
don't care I'm telling I'm telling a
joke and you can't do anything about it
he basically plants a flag and now
regular people can stop being scared and
call out the crackpots that they don't
like that's part of the reason why 2024
is going to be kind of or one of the
many factors that is going to make 2024
kind of crazy the people that are
interested in social justice as leg as
legislation they are going to be holding
on to power they're going to be doing
whatever they can to pass
legislation that that benefits their
ideology and it's the same thing as like
when when the Allies were going towards
uh towards Germany they just ramped up
the killing the Jews because there it's
an ideology they like part of their
ideology was kill the Jews part of the
ideology of the left right now is to
implement social justice stuff into law
so they're going to be doing all they
can to to Ram laws that are as permanent
as possible through before the the
election in order to to you know hope
with in their opinion
hopefully push this as far as they can
because they I it's it's likely they see
that there's going to be a a a swing
back of the pendulum I think I'm glad
that they've overreached and they've
gone so far it's like jiujitsu you're we
can use their own momentum against them
because they've gone so far people don't
agree with it that Dave Chappelle making
what seems to be an inoffensive joke to
anybody in the world is completely
offensive to these people to the point
where they want to kill him and Sh shout
out to Dave Chappelle by the way the
only person to make a funny joke about
me that I enjoyed from the D me bro
thing like 15 years ago the only one
that made a joke I enjoy so sh shout out
to Dave Chappelle and uh I'm glad he's
doing his own material and not just uh
copying Owen Benjamin anymore just just
kidding just kidding well you you got
you got made fun of by Dave Chappelle
and that's when I when I we were
watching it
and he he second joke in the ACT is M
mocking Madison cauthorne I was like man
how lucky is Madison cauthorne yeah he
was a member of Congress I mean not like
not like uh uh you know he probably
would have been happier if he didn't get
Prim married but for Dave Chappelle to
do a comedy special making fun of you as
a member of Congress you you are you are
Immortal the joke he makes about you in
that moment and uh he says he saw him
and he yelled hey congressman and he
looks over him and he's mad and he's
like and then and then and and then I
walked away I wanted to see him do some
I wanted to see I wanted him to see me
do something he couldn't do that's what
he
says I'm like yo if that were me I was
getting made fun of by Dave Chappelle
I'd be like man honor honor it's a total
honor it's like why I love shows like
kill Tony too like Tony hinchcliff like
just roasting people that that to me is
the way my that's my favorite type of
Comedy not just the surreal stuff which
I also like but people just ragging on
you it feels it's that's catharsis and
that's why a lot of like when I saw
Louie get like quote unquote canceled
all those years ago I was like that was
the beginning of me really understanding
like they're going to take out artists
and comedy first cuz those are the
people who subvert the whole power
structure right and then Louis handled
it I thought very poorly with the
apology and stuff but and Chappelle did
the opposite thing he just doubled down
which I I appreciate that to me no I you
say to me it's like that's that's more
punk rock what Chappelle does is punk
rock you know Lou didn't when when I got
uh one of the times when people were
like giving me crap and in response I
wrote a song called Never
sorry that's how you do it is that's
exactly how you do it right like you
were saying earlier like you only let
yourself be canceled right they can't do
it too of course you can lose your jobs
and stuff and like they've got normal
people in the world who lose their jobs
but uh once you apologize that gives
them all the power over you you're
admitting you're admitting guilt unless
you did something wrong you feel bad for
it like go ahead and apologize but like
that's so rare but the thing is when you
are going to apologize you have to
apologize to a person that possesses the
ability to forgive you when you
apologize to a community no one has the
power to forgive you and they're gonna
use it against you in the future because
you've admitted to it and then five
years two years whatever down the road
when you pop up in someone's you know
sites again and they're like oh I
remember that guy he did this terrible
thing that we can crap on him again so
all I'm going to do is bring this up and
we can totally disregard what he says
don't give them the power don't say I'm
sorry because then you're telling them I
consent to your authority over me
demanding an apology so I will allow you
to have that power over me get effed you
have no power don't be afraid to be
called anything any bad words Elon
buying Twitter was massive absolutely I
was here a just about a year ago and I
was banned from Twitter not aloud I I
shouted out a bunch of people Patriot J
old Rose Swig all banned and today
they're all back Alex Jones is back
Patriot J is great Jones shout out
Patriot J yeah crazy it's a different
world with Alex Jones back on Twitter
and with Elon letting him grow and grow
and grow so 2024 it's it's the best of
times it's the worst of times you know
hundreds of thousands coming through the
southern border but at the same time
Alex Jones being popular in mainstream
on Twitter very very different year
we're going to have it feels like meme
magic is here in full effect that that
is one thing I'm afraid of though
because the counterculture is going to
swing so hard back and now with people
like Alex back um but I feel like
they're going to find a way to subvert
our subversion you know like they're
going to find a way to just turn off the
power you know thing is that bothers me
when you're when you're subversive or
when you're when you're dealing with
people like you know in in the world
that we deal in where're outside of the
mainstream narrative like just because
you hear a story that's outside of the
mainstream narrative doesn't mean it's
true or it's right and that's one of the
things that that the people that are
outside of the mainstream need to be
focused on right now just because
someone that is ex that is looked at as
outside of the the acceptable
conversation says something doesn't mean
they're correct in fact you have to be
more careful now we've had that fire
drill once before the Q andon thing
everybody saw Q anon's not real I think
people are a little wiser than they were
last go around that people are being
able to spot whatever they try to throw
at us I think there is a decent
probability of some kind of cyber 9911
people call it and that something cuz I
think it was like was it Bill Gates who
was talking about this the risk of our
digital infrastructure and and cyber
attacks Imagine This scen scario uh
first let me just say I don't know the
probability but I think there is a
possibility considering the stakes of
2024 the internet has gone down before
there have been cyber attacks over the
past several years we note them and then
uh there was one where Google actually
went down and all of a sudden nobody
could get to their websites because
people don't actually type in the
websites they type in the word press
enter and it pulls up Google which they
then click the thing what I'm searching
for things on Twitter I don't search
Twitter I search Google I'll type in
like Phil leonti communist meme X and
then it'll pop up with like his latest
post and I'll click that's how I find it
so when Google went down I forgot
exactly what happened all of a sudden
internet traffic dropped dramatically
imagine a scenario where for some reason
the Internet is just down just in in
general and the only information com out
is through terrestrial television CNN
Fox News MSNBC imagine during the
election we get some kind of attack and
that's what happens imagine if just
before the election something like that
happens they can then say whatever they
want without being fact checked by
anybody else and no one can discount
them there may be a scenario like that I
don't know um it could be like oh no we
get attacked and the infrastructure goes
down and oh we better fix it we don't
know what's going on and it's an act of
War which we then use to justify some
kind of escalation somewhere else but
then also allows them to basically say
to a show like ours if you want to stay
on the air it's going to cost you like
what what do they charge a th000 bucks
an hour or something something for for
dedicated satellite and uh what youall
need to understand about the way YouTube
works this is only possible this show is
only possible because YouTube pays for
the streaming costs what people need to
understand is when we we are streaming
right now at about uh 6,000 kilobits per
second that means for the 45,000 people
watching it receiving between 2,000 and
6,000 multiply that multiply that 6,000
by 45,000 and you'll get the actual data
trans transer there's no possible way we
could afford that it's only possible
because of these website subsidies so
when you see like Rumble they're
spending a pretty penny to get those
shows out because they want to make that
work so shout out to rumble YouTube of
course is subsidized by by Google it's
not it's not that extreme we may
actually be able to uh uh like what we
what we would just do is it's 10 bucks a
month to subscribe to the show and then
we could use that money to pay for the
for the stream and all that stuff but it
just basically it would make it make it
so that literally anybody who wants to
watch has to to pay they're they're I I
believe that's their best attack Vector
for shutting down the kind of things I
agree I mean there's been so many
reports about the internet apocalypse
and they're worried about solar flares
but from what I'm hearing solar flares
won't wouldn't probably affect it I
think what they would do is blame it on
a solar flare and then just shut it off
you know on their own and then prevent
us from uh subverting the narrative like
a lot of us were doing during lockdowns
or you know talking about election stuff
uh that's going to be tough that's why
I've been I've been very open in my
community about how I feel about
everything you know building a people in
my immediate Community who I know I can
trust and agree with you know maybe
nothing will happen but I don't want to
be in in a spot again where I'm
surrounded by a bunch of idiots like I
was in New York and and not handle like
the society just being ripped to shreds
I think even the speculation of us
talking about this it puts a it puts a a
wrench in their plans because if
everybody is thinking ahead of time oh
these people want to do something evil
to stop us if something like this were
to go down everyone knows where to point
the finger so Tim speculating like this
Alex Jones when he speculates on Grand
conspiracies these things help to put a
wrench and stop their plant so I'm glad
that we're doing this right now people
are thinking ahead what are these evil
bastards thinking of next everybody's
looking this is the source this is the
problem and you know hopefully uh people
pull the lever and figure out Donald
Trump is where we need to go
2024 let's see I have it I have a couple
stories I want to start with this one
the New York Post this is this is crazy
cops recover suicide note after a
deranged man drove car packed with
explosives into crowd at Rochester
concert killing two so apparently what
happened was this guy loaded his SUV
with explosives I believe it was
gasoline or something and he was trying
to ram a crowd of people as an Uber
pulled out he then T-boned the Uber
killing the people inside and uh uh
injuring several others around it but I
believe that Uber may have inadvertently
saved many lives it's a wild story this
happened I believe it happened on the 1
and uh they believe it may be a terror
attack it's being investigated as an act
of terrorism we will see but what a way
to kick off
2024 so as we're seeing stories like
this you know I get to thinking uh about
the conversations I had with family
extended family members over the uh
holiday and they ask questions about
like do you really like you talk about
Civil War but like like what what's the
likelihood you really think and I'm just
like time travel test man if you went
look right now the corporate press says
that a bunch of men conspired to kidnap
Gretchen Whitmer now obviously we
contest a lot of those allegations the
corporate press says that January 6 an
Insurrection was attempted to all these
leftists who are calling me crazy for
saying I fear Civil War they're the same
people claiming that Donald Trump
literally tried to start a civil war
it's the weirdest thing like Donald
Trump tried to overthrow the government
in a in in a coup with his supporters
who stormed and attacked the capital
Civil War will never happen like uh then
you're not scared of trump and his
supporters and MAA in
2024 Aris rinos I'm probably pronouncing
his name wrong I worked with him briefly
uh when I was at Vice news he's a good
dude he says he writes for unheard the
world should fear 2024 escalation lurks
on every Battlefield now of course he
talks mainly about foreign policy but he
does mention in the article that
escalation will exists in American
domestic uh discourse as well so I
think man you know we got a Super Chat
already saying beware the Ides of March
I'm like come on bro that's like three
it's like 2 and a half months from now
literally it's 2 and a half months from
now wow when we had Eric Prince on just
before the end of the year I asked him
is there something like what does he
what does he see here in the United
States does he see anything happening
you know akin to this with with what
he's seen in other countries and he he
said the one thing that every guy who's
been in a civil war Revolution period
and conflict and crisis can tell you is
that it happens overnight one day
everything's normal you wake up there's
no electricity there's no radio there's
no internet that's what people don't
realize you may go outside and go to the
mall and you're like everything feels
normal and this is the normaly bias that
people on Twitter talk about on on X
they'll say oh you guys talk about all
this stuff go touch grass because when
you go to the mall when you go to the
movies no one cares about any of the
stuff and I'm like right in Egypt during
the revolution nobody cared about this
stuff so let me tell you I went to a
place called utag do you guys know what
that is no do you know what Barrow
Alaska is yes yeah they changed the name
in
2016 uh the native I believe it's the in
inak people referred to the area as UT
gagik UT is it UT kagic yeah it's UT
kagic and uh when Western settlers came
they referred to it as Barrow uh Point
Barrow or whatever and then those
settlers built up a training post in a
city that they called
Barrow in uh 2016 a group of activists
this is this is what I was told by uh
some of the locals that I had met they
said that like 86 people voted it's it's
a town of four 4,500 people it's like 86
people voted and it was like by one or
two votes to change the name to utvic
and so I was like the school says Barrow
on it the airport calls it Barrow the
the uh Airlines call it Barrow the
airport is called Barrow brw but they
changed the name and he's like it was
like 40s something people and I'm like
40s something people voted and changed
the name of your city and he goes it's
still Barrow I heard that from several
people and I tweeted about it I was like
wow dude some decolonized activists were
like this place is called utag not
Barrow so we're going to hold a vote
nobody shows up nobody cared and so 40
people I tweeted this out and it's
really funny because I got a mix of
people uh who are like you're racists
for not supporting indigenous people's
rights even though I did not criticize
the name change at all the point I made
was twofold do not let a small group of
psychopaths dis change your community
without your consent and more
importantly that famous saying never uh
let it never be said that a small group
of dedicated people can't change the
world indeed it's the only thing that
ever did 40 some odd people decided to
change the name of that City and they
did it that was my point and then I get
people being like you just hate Natives
and Native Americans and I was like I'm
from Illinois dude I don't care that
they call it utag that's fine I know I
my friends from alanin like the names of
all of our places are native I don't
care are are are like the the you know
Eskimos or the Inuit people are they
really all that angry at the white man
it's not like the white man took their
land nobody wants that property I don't
believe so I believe actually a good
portion of the people
again I'm not from there so I don't know
but I the the way it was explained to me
is this is probably like it's like white
liberals woke people I was told woke
people yeah so yes it probably does
include some of the indigenous but the
the natives didn't really talk about it
all that much I don't know it didn't
didn't seem like it wasn't an issue
mostly when I met one native guy who was
really excited to explain how they kill
whales and it was it was wild how he
told us how they do it he's been talking
to the same 10 people for the past 30
years he oh yeah and then he sees us and
he's like here's what we do I tell the
same stories to these new people and
they're going to react this going to be
awesome dude the the the native dude who
explained wailing did not come up to us
and be like the white man did this and
did that he was like let me tell you how
we kill whales and I'm like it's illegal
for us to kill whales and he's like yeah
but not us I thought that was kind of
crazy too but it was it was wild to see
as we're coming into
2024 I I'll remind people
of I'm in Egypt during the revolution
and I went to heliopolis went to the
mall people were buying burgers and just
living their life and I got a kebab it
was delicious and I went to a store and
I bought a cell phone it was like
nothing was happening meanwhile there
was a revolution in taher square
Blackhawks flying overhead apcs through
the streets people were shooting and
killing each other but out a block away
at the McDonald's seriously it's like
two blocks McDonald's two blocks away I
think it's McDonald's uh from T there's
a guy just eating a burger and fries and
watching soccer if more people had had a
firstand experience with that or or knew
someone that did and understood that
there would be far fewer people saying
that a civil war will never happen in
the United States because a civil war
absolutely could happen in the United
States doesn't mean that everybody's
going to be involved doesn't mean that
people aren't still going to go to work
it's never everybody it's always some
tiny tiny faction and and the issue is
you take a look at what happened with
the culture War and the shift most
regular people did not like wokeness but
were too afraid to say anything think
about how many people didn't want to go
along with the mandates but did because
they were scared that they couldn't do
it there's one video where a guy a
woman's filming and a guy's stalking her
in a super supermarket saying she's not
wearing a mask if we have to wear masks
she has to wear masks you see what they
were really mad about the oppression and
they want you know misery loves company
so anyway my point is this as we're
seeing this stuff entering
2024 dude if if the people who are on
Twitter like go touch grass these people
have no idea what conflict is actually
like go watch the videos from the
destruction of Aleppo and what will you
see you'll see people walking with bags
of groceries through Rubble filled
battlefields with gunfire someone's
going grocery shopping you talk to that
person what they're worried about and
they're like oh I got to get milk for my
family yeah that's touching grass I
think the pain points are starting to
increase though because the guy that
just wants to go get milk for his family
what happened to the price of that milk
what happened to the price at the pump
and I think hundreds and hundreds of
thousands of migrants we keep seeing the
videos I just was in the Phoenix Airport
you could see the illegal immigrants all
over the the floor over there just like
Ashley stclair and Taylor Hansen took
video of uh in Europe when you had that
number of migrants and now they're
coming from Africa they're coming from
the Middle East it's not just it's like
they've emptied out Central America
already into America uh when you have
that level of migrants they're doing
inordinate amounts of crime crazy
amounts of crime and the pain points of
everyday Americans we keep having these
this many people come through the
southern border that pain point is going
to increase to the normies paying
attention I think that normies are
actually starting to get tuned into a a
crazy uh level than they used to be that
video of that margorie Taylor green
posted where you can see the thousands
running under the barrier and running in
when I showed that to normies they
flipped out yeah and I'm I'm not
exaggerating they were just like what
what is that what's going on and I'm
like that's our border right now and
they're like we don't have a country
anymore if that's the case most people
are like Maryann Williamson remember I
mean she was appalled at most of the
things that we showed her she had no
idea completely and totally ignorant and
this woman is running for president and
ostensibly has access to as much
information as she could possibly want
but like we were talking about earlier
people are afraid to go to to to uh
platforms like this or come to places
like this and because of that they are
fed a narrative that is not based in
reality that is not based in facts on
the ground and they they look at actual
real things when they hear about them
and they they're shocked just the other
night I was hanging out with uh some
other parents that we know and they're
fairly apolitical but they understand
more or less you know what kind of
what's going on but not to any degree
that we talk about sure and I felt I
started to feel bad because I was
telling them about my reporting from
Yuma and I felt like I was breaking
their hearts and their spirit cuz they
were so appalled and I'm like and I I
kept going cuz I'm like I'm not even
done I have so much more to tell you it
is so crazy dystopian down there and I
could see it in their eyes being like
this is insane um it's so alarming and
then back to the the Civil War stuff I
always think about the day before
lockdown in New York in the suburbs
where I was I I it dawned on me to go
report from a gun store and see what was
going on cuz there was like this fear
being pumped in I was thinking about
there's this band Phil you know what I'm
talking about every time I die they have
a lyric called paranoia is the disease
of the unarmed I think that's from last
night in town and I thought of that
sentence that lyric and I was like I'm
going to go to the gun store and see
what's going on it's a great line I went
to the gun shop it was Mayhem there were
people running in who never owned a gun
buying rifles and shotguns I saw two
people in such panic mode leave their
guns there after they buy they bought
them I saw another guy outside leave his
gun on the car and drive off without it
they were fre it was there was nothing
on the walls anymore the ammo was gone I
got a lot of ammo from my shotgun but
like it was crazy watching people and so
like at that point soet hadn't collapsed
the way it has now and they were just
afraid of other people and they got to
protect themselves and in uh my my
favorite thing about it was in in
California there was a guy who owned a
gun store posted a video and he was like
stop yelling at me that you can't buy a
gun it's not my fault you voted for
weight periods you voted for these
restrictions and now you have to abide
by them here's the reality though it was
funny to watch but these liberals didn't
vote for anything yeah this is the issue
with wokeness UT gagik exemplifies it
when the vote was announced that they
were going to change the name 4,500
people said I don't care and you know
what to be fair I honestly don't care
the name is UT gagik versus Barrow like
I said I'm from Illinois you know they
they they initially wanted to name West
Virginia kanoa these are Native American
terms in Illinois you've got like I
mentioned El ganin a lot of these places
are named by the Native Americans
because the colonist who came in didn't
just make up new names for it what's it
called Illinois okay great we'll call it
Illinois right and and then and then
there's uh many things that they did
name that's totally fine on this issue
though my point
is a small amount of people who do care
will take from you everything you hold
dear if you don't pay attention so when
this guy tells me it's still called
Barrow I'm like buddy no it's not mhm we
went to a restaurant and there was this
old guy who's like I've been here for 47
years and there's very few restaurants
it was was Top of the World it was it
was great and I had reindeer delicious
did you eat eat
Christmas uh no we were there on
Christmas okay but uh we ate a lot of
reindeer like everything's just got
reindeer up there cuz they cuz they uh
they Farm them they Farm reindeer for
meat and so but I'm this old guy
separate guy asked them I was like I see
on the map it says gag but the airport
says Barrow and he goes it's Barrow and
and they all said basically the same
thing a bunch of like a small group
people voted and now everyone's claiming
it's the official name but it's Barrow
and I'm just like my guy when you die
it's utaki right have a nice day it's
like states and cities do it too it
reminds me of like the tapenz bridge in
New York they it's now the Mario Cuomo
bridge but no one calls it that Willis
Tower Willis Tower yeah Sears Tower oh
right you go to Chicago in official
reports they'll say the Willis Tower but
the average person will call it the
Sears Tower wow that's crazy yeah and
like there's a ton of roads like that in
New York no but they try they try gu
field oh all the stadiums that are now
named after banks are disgusting too
it's so gross but my my point with 2024
is is is simply simply put all these
people who are like a civil war won't
happen cuz most people don't care
bro you may end up in a period where
they change the name of your city and
you'll be like I didn't even know that
was happening yeah because the activists
are paying attention they're organized
they know what's up and they're ready
for action yep I think we're in an era
of Consciousness it's not so much force
anymore and if the people really want
change we can actually have an election
even with everything that they did in
2020 all the irregularity
uh I think that if the amalgamation of
the energy of the people is such that we
deserve a good King then a good King
will sit on the throne if people return
to God if people pray if people love
their neighbor they do the right things
uh we can have a good King in this
country and I'm not going to I I see
your scenario it the other side always
wants to do evil and when you're talking
about Civil War I'm thinking about all
these hundreds of thousands of migrants
that would be the war it's an invasion
they can a lot of these people are from
all kinds of organizations they can
activate to do crazy things in this
country that type of scenario exists for
sure but I just look at things like how
can the good people win that's always
the scenario I'm looking how can the
good people win and if if people were
turn to God we can have a good King we
can save America a potential scenario I
see is that Donald Trump wins we cheer
uh it's a tough battle but Donald Trump
wins and one of the first things he does
is begin what will be the largest
deportation effort ever seen which he
promised which he promises and then you
will get videos and photos of the Trump
Administration and the National Guard in
the Army rounding up immigrants illegal
immigrants onto trains and buses and of
course they're going to be held in camps
and holding facilities and then when the
civil war starts they're going to show
pictures of what Trump did with the IM
immigrants to what Hitler did with the
Nazis and they're going to say never
again don't let it repeat and they're
going to use that propaganda to Rally
people then the left activist will be
able to go to illegal immigrants and say
would you like to defend your right to
be here fight with us so potential
scenario I'm not saying likely probable
I'm just saying a potentiality is Donald
Trump has promised the largest
deportation we've ever seen you have 8
to 10 million illegal immigrants and
every day 10,000 more Donald Trump will
have to put them on trains and buses
they will have to be brought to camps
Chicago is already building camps I want
to stress this Chicago it got delayed
it's postponed it may not happen I'm not
sure but they announced they're going to
be building a migrant Camp what do you
think is it's going to look like do
people think these things are going to
they're going to look like they're
they're going to be slums they're going
to be places with limited resources
where the people will be screaming and
complaining living in their own filth
and they're going to be confined to it
because there's too many of them the
people of Chicago are complaining what
happens in that scenario where a civil
war does start in 2025 or 6 and they use
these images to to make it look like
Trump is Hitler claiming he's doing it
it's happening again blah blah blah they
already called the migrant detention
centers concentration camps this what
I'm saying here is not something I just
made up top made up off the top of my
head I'm saying AOC already said he has
concentration camps Donald Trump does
Donald Trump has already promised
deportation effort several cities have
already announced they're going to build
camps Alex Jones called this by the way
like 15 20 years ago he did he said that
that FEMA is going to set up detention
centers likely for illegal immigrants 20
years later we'll see we'll see maybe
we'll add some more money than Alex
Jones's right jar but based on the
pieces that are already on the table I'm
like oh combine them Donald Trump Mass
deportation effort Mass illegal
immigration AOC and Democrats saying
concentration camp they are going to
produce tons of propaganda to liken
Donald Trump to Hitler to use as a
rallying
cry after that we speculate if conflict
breaks out they're going to try and make
it seem like World War II and they're
the good guys I just don't think that
they're popular anymore I see I see the
scenario you're trying to play out I see
the propaganda that they can push matter
I was going to say the same thing and
then I was then thinking about what Tim
was saying about there small group of
people it takes to be insane to cause it
you know which could be the case do you
how many people in Seattle are willing
to go outside and walk up to antifa
armed with AR-15s and tell them to GTFO
cuz the answer was none so even though I
think it's fair to say you knock on any
door in Seattle and say how do you feel
about the far leftist with guns taking
over Capitol Hill they're going to be
like hey man I think that sffs crazy I'm
with you man but I just don't want to
say anything we all know the majority of
people were like yeah I totally agree
with you on Trump but I better not speak
up Owen Shroyer goes to prison and the
guards say yeah I like what you do man
but I'm just doing my job this country
is r with evil I sent Owen a bunch of
books by the way funny little story I
sent Owen Troyer a bunch of books while
he was in jail they returned the
envelope to me with like a dirty wife
beater shirt in it so they opened it he
told me they didn't give him the books
so they took them and they returned the
envelope to me with like a dirty shirt
in it just funny little story that is
bizarre yeah bizarre but this this is my
point let's say woke people make up like
10 12% of the country but that we know
that they're violent and they're angry
and they're crazy mhm so a large
percentage of them are organized and
could mobilize let's say they do in a
place like Seattle if Donald Trump gets
elected and uh he does begin you know
arresting people we already saw a guy
tried firebombing an ice facility inoma
that happened several years ago so what
happens when these college groups go to
their front and say guys you know you
have to join us and they go oh man what
do you do do you come out let me let me
tell you another story so a lot of
people are incorrectly stating that uh
Abraham Lincoln was kept off the ballot
in 10 states not true the way it worked
back then was that the parties would
issue the ballots and you'd go and drop
them off the deal was when you voted you
voted you wrote down who you wanted to
vote for so the Democrats the
Republicans the Democrat Republicans the
wigs whatever would say here's our list
of people you could take that ballot
from them and then be like I'm going to
vote for this party here are all the
people I want and there you go you cast
your vote I'm assuming they drop in a
box or something so they say Abraham
Lincoln was taken off the ballot in 10
states he wasn't taken off the
Republicans didn't issue ballots in 10
states because for one they they're like
the states hate us we're not going to
win but the the fear was if you were
seen holding paraphernalia of the
Republican party in a slave state you
would be mercilessly beaten at worst
shunned at best so no one was willing to
cast a vote for republicans in these
states so Abraham Lincoln received zero
votes in the states that went on to
seced that form the Confederacy I'm
thinking right now about El Salvador
which I believe had the highest murder
rate in Central America if you had told
me five years ago that El Salvador it
didn't it didn't have the highest murder
rate it was very high it had a high
murder rate very high murder rate
Honduras has one of the highest murder
rates in the world okay so let's say
second third High what a very high
murder rate um if you told me 5 years
ago that that place would suddenly be
like
attracting Americans to take citizenship
move to El Salvador I don't want to
mispronounce the president of El
Salvador's name let's just say it's Max
Kaiser it's not
maxer na bu that's how you say na bu
thank you uh he turned that country
around I would never have thought a dime
I never would have thought that the will
of the people existed to turn El
Salvador from dystopian murder nightmare
into Argentina attracting
Americans so I I I I see the potential
for negative in America but I also see
that we can flip this country for the
good yes I agree I think it's important
to point out that while we're looking at
you know conflict chaos crisis and all
that stuff we're still winning
culturally and that's why they're
getting desperate it may be that it's a
2024 gets wild there's riots it's crazy
Donald Trump ends up winning it's
contested but he clears it and then he
starts arresting people deportations
happen and then things start simmering
down as he weeds out the corruption mhm
it may be that Donald Trump is just
plainly successful and we avoid the
worst of it I hope so I think you know
we experienced real dystopia during
lockdowns we had Chaz we had like rapper
and like Seattle with a flamethrower
just take over a block it and they
unloaded hundreds of rounds into a white
Su innocent people were murdered
Minnesota uh Portland St Louis St St
Louis had a had had a occupation they
well they had all the arson uh they burn
down those building ATA had an
occupation and Minnesota had an
occupation and uh uh Seattle Port tried
a couple times to see like it could get
crazier but I also know so many people
saw those things go down who weren't
like engaged at all politically like
that can't happen again like I know
people who were in I think it was
Atlanta and they lived in like in a
skyscraper and they're stuck on their
roof watching as people down below are
just destroying everything and there's
people out their Windows throwing flower
pots at them and stuff it was just like
a zombie movie in New York that was in
Atlanta oh wow yeah like like we're
we're
seeing York was crazy too New York was
crazy because there were people calling
the police and the police were just like
good luck yeah unless you were unless
like there were rabbis getting arrested
in the park in Brooklyn you know those
guys got arrested but you could ride you
could burn anything you want just don't
praise God but this is this is this is
the important thing to understand it's
not that necessarily the city wants the
Riders it's that they're impotent yeah
so when there was one famous story where
uh a guy a fight broke out in the lobby
of his apartment building so he called
the police and they and the woman said
sir the city is under attack what would
you have us do let me tell you tell you
guys something play Fallout 3 okay in
Fallout 3 there's a uh fallout a video
game nuclear war happens people seal
themselves in vaults the vaults are not
good things but long story short they
start emerging afterwards and there are
people who survived the nuclear war and
have built small civil small societies
outside of it and then the Vault
dwellers come out there's also a group
called The
Enclave which is highly Advanced with
powerful military bases clean running
water and they are the it's been
hundreds of years but they're the
remnants of the American government they
are not good guys they kill you my point
about bringing that up is it's it's a
simple understanding the game developers
had when they created the concept of The
Enclave if the city falls into chaos the
police are not going to help
you World War Z people pointed out when
the dude is Brad Pitt's character is
going to get the medicine for his
daughter and then he sees the cop come
in he's like oh crap and the cop looks
at him and then just runs straight up
and grabs and loots and then runs away
that's a great point to be made yeah
when everything breaks down and there's
riots in the streets and it's bad the
police are going to be thinking two
things I need to protect my family
that's the first thing and the second is
who's got my back so when you call
they're not going to answer they're
going to be like bro you want me to
leave my family and my friends right now
in my fortified Police Department with
guns to come to your house to fight some
crazy crackpot ain't happening good
luck what is it paranoia is a disease of
the unarmed yes I love that we were
talking about every time I die lyrics
every time I die is great yes great band
go check out but it's a great that's a
great lyric we're going to go to super
chats so if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends if you do like it and
head over to
timcast.net Bally how we run this whole
thing so we greatly appreciate it all
right here we go Quantum strange cork
says am I the first of the new
year uh uh New Year New Year timcast
family is at a member 33 months is a
member wow that is uh that makes you the
first Super Chat of the New Year
yay we got balloons coming down yeah you
can't see them there in the
corner Shane says Tim leaves for a week
and all hell breaks loose in the news
cycle y'all deserved the break though
welcome back yeah next year we already
talked about it we're probably going to
do a big New Year's bash where because
it's on Tuesday New Year's Eve will be a
Tuesday that's kind of weird is it I
don't know Tuesday it's like a o day for
it but uh we'll probably take the next
day off but the plan is Regular Show
Monday uh New Year's Eve big Jam because
uh we're probably going to be at the new
studio in a few weeks I I I've seen the
photos they look
amazing it's so cool I'm so excited skat
Park is going to take a couple months
but the uh the kitchen is done the uh
new studio which is for the new shows is
empty and needs but it's like the room
is there so now the studio the the the
the art decoration buildout for the the
cameras is next the new timcast studio
same deal it's done the uh construction
the the the uh set design and and and
Studio Building Company is coming out in
a couple weeks super excited and uh The
Green Room they the pictures of the bar
it's basically done we just got to put a
TV in it nice we're going to get a nice
little couch and like a little hangout
area there's a spiral staircase that
goes to the ceiling it's amazing so it's
a 40ft tall building with a three-story
Building inside of it yeah and so uh
we're getting really close to being
there and then we're going to slowly
build up all the really awesome stuff
and we're going to do a big New Year's
Eve Jam for the next year depending on
what happens I guess it'll be pretty
wild but uh that's the plan for next
year but anyway as for the the break we
had no choice we were like going over
the dates and I'm like yo nobody wants
to to fly out the week of Christmas
there's no question after Christmas
nobody's getting on a plane and flying
out to come on a show there's potential
locals we could maybe do something and
then Democrats went nuts Nikki Haley
said the Civil War was about the
government taking our freedoms and I was
like Wow and then Maine pulled Trump off
the uh the the ballot I was like I knew
Democrats would pull some BS it's the
one week I'm I'm off you know what I
mean but I went to uh we went to Barrow
Alaska first and hung out and then we
went to Anchorage and hung out that was
that was cool and then we went to
Fairbanks and as soon as we landed at
Fairbanks we get into the parking lot it
was minus 28 Aurora Borealis massive
right above
usus yeah we went dog sleding and it was
funny because atus 28 within like 5
minutes you've got icicles on your
eyelashes your beard is all white I
shaved afterwards and um my eyebrows
were all covered in icycles cuz when you
breathe the humidity collects and slowly
starts getting bigger and bigger and
then you got to like warm up and wipe it
off yeah it's a lot of fun I heard I
heard from a reliable source that Alaska
has the headquarters of where they make
the fake clouds was that was that true I
don't know if you heard that or not
Shane likes to jokingly say that clouds
are fake joking jokingly and they have
uh probably a power plant so there's
steam coming out of the stacks you know
relieving pressure or whatever it might
be I don't know but the thing is it was
so cold the they stay mhm so you
literally have we always make the joke
when you see the steam coming out of a
power plant it's like they're making
clouds but the steam dissipates not
there it's so cold there's one big cloud
and it goes right down from one building
you're like wow they really are making
clouds I've asked him they're literally
making clouds I've asked him to to drop
me off at the headquarters next that's
that's invert world was funny I sent you
that one video of it but there was like
50 of those buildings it's like steam
exhaust or something I want to go down
to the bottom of this but I know I know
someone there's a Super Chat asking
about my restaurant review I will
elaborate when I read it because
everyone's like there was one bad review
all right Jacob parody says stay sharp
this year don't do anything stupid and
don't get baited by the left here
here poly PI says glad that Tim cast is
back my favorite show thank you so much
for watching the show appreciate it
share with your friends it's the most
important thing um we got to figure out
I we're not good at marketing um I mean
like it's actually not true we're
actually really good at it but we don't
do it effectively for what we're trying
to do so we're thinking of doing like a
commercial on YouTube or something you
know the show is successful in spite of
YouTube they suppress us and everybody
knows this they do goofy things with our
thumbnails they do goofy things with
like the video not appearing we get it
we get it but um I think we're going to
go for some conventional marketing just
I don't know we'll figure it out
probably do a big YouTube campaign just
saying come watch the
show yeah I wonder you know we'll just
we'll just why not gota do something
Zachary McCoy says I'm near De Moine
where do I get a ticket do we know where
the tickets are are they up yet they
they might be they might be up already
and they probably soon as soon as they
go out as soon as tickets go out they're
getting sold out like 50 it's like 50
tickets and um it's a it's a small it is
a cozy event venue I can't say too much
because you'll get the info if you buy
the tickets but it's going to be like a
very intimate setting where we're
hanging out and doing the show and so
it's going to be it's going to be
awesome and we're going to there are
tickets but we're going to be vetting
the people who want to buy the tickets
so there's strong possibility people in
the audience will be asking questions
and things like that like normal Town
Hall but
I'll just stress because this was put
together so quickly I don't have all the
details just yet so waiting to hear back
yeah Shane's uh going to hear back on
tickets I think we announced it the
announced it this morning and uh you
know so I'm like well my Show's not
until later we'll announce it but v v
announced we're doing our town hall with
him and I gotta be honest I think we
will get substantially more views on
ours than CNN will I I think that's a
given um I think well you know it's
tough to say to be fair On Any Given
night we Crush CNN in the key demo
ratings handily like 5 to 10x it's it's
kind of really bad wow yeah I mean CNN
gets nothing they get like 70,000 we get
like four or 500 um but they got Ron and
Nikki they might get a million so they
might you know do more than we would but
I think it'll be to a certain degree
comparable I guess I guess the other
issue too is it's going to be a
multi-way goop battle you know will
people choose to watch the CNN debates
or choose to watch the V Town Hall that
we
or trumps you know people might uh I
wonder if there's any people out there
who are even stuck between choosing
disantis over V you know it was a
crossover look I think one of the
reasons that people watched the previous
debates was because of V oh for sure
he's he's he's the the the the the
cinjun spice thrown into the mix I got
to be honest with you man when I went to
Thailand I told my friend I was like I
want real Thai food cuz I love pod Thai
he's like yeah okay man you want real
Thai food let me show you what it's all
about and he brings me to this uh Little
Restaurant it's the corner of a street
and it's got two big garage door like
doors that open up so it's like a patio
almost I sit down he orders and thae and
guess what authentic thae food is
steamed chicken and rice that's it
that's it they bring out a bowl of rice
and some steamed chicken and I was like
it's good but it's literally just
steamed chicken and rice that's funny I
went to Brazil and told my friend I want
some real Brazilian food he like okay
I'll bring you to the place and guess
what it is
steak beef and rice and I like H you
know the stuff that we eat here it's all
like fake yep so uh I forgot where I was
going with that but that was what were
we talking about fancy food I don't know
where we were before that I don't know
Ron and Nikki oh yeah crossover cross
from and and Sant exactly that's where
we were my point is this we like steak I
think steak's fantastic like you give me
a raw steak I'll annihilate I I'll I'll
or a steak blue I don't care I hope
there's no parasites in it but you know
when you get a good like cinjun spice
rub on your wings oh come on we love
Cent spice don't we yeah oh watching
those debates with aake I was just like
that that's a guy who's good at
podcasting and those are people who are
good at sound bites for Fox you know and
he was just running laps it is uh it is
interesting to listen to Nory you know
discuss their impression of of a because
obviously he's not doing all that well
in the polls and I don't think that
there's a lot of people that say oh if
it wasn't for Donald Trump vake would be
higher in the polls and I don't know
that I believe that I like v a lot he's
actually I think that I'm going to
probably vote for him in the uh in the
uh primaries um but I don't think that
he he connects with people the way that
he connects with me and I don't think
that he connects with people the way
that I wish he did yeah uh and and but
but I
think V is targeting the the new wave
like he's thinking forward he's thinking
ahead he's ahead of the market on this
one sure so what is what is what is
lacking who watches CNN okay Tucker
Carlson was getting 3 million views per
night not anymore CNN's not in the
airport anymore true the the the the
average age for these terrestrial cable
channels is like 67 or 70 yeah and that
used to be the way to consume news and
now for uh even many of the of of our uh
senior friends they're watching shows
like this but the reason why we Crush
CNN in the key demo because this is how
young younger people are consuming media
social media podcasts not CNN so when we
look at CNN's ratings that they're high
but when you look at their key demo
ratings they're in the gutter like
seriously like 70k on some of their
shows 70,000 they're a dinosaur they're
going the way of the newspaper nobody
reads newspapers anymore nobody's going
to be watching cable news that's the and
and I got to be honest there will come a
time where people don't watch this show
anymore and it's going to be like Ah
that's for old people young people are
all doing metaverse stuff who knows who
knows but for the time being this is
where the voting demo and the money demo
is at and CN doesn't have it anyway my
point was watching Ron and Nikki will be
be like ordering steamed rice and
steamed chicken it's like it's food and
you'd be happy to have it if there's
nothing else but you've also got Donald
Trump on Fox News and V ramaswami on
timcast and with Donald Trump you're
talking about getting a gigantic greasy
you know mutton you know right there
that you can just annihilate it's in a
big basket with french fries and you got
the mayonnaise and you're like this is
going to be a meal and then with fa it's
it's like a very perfectly planned out
like properly spiced like Trump's the
big burger Big Mac and and then n is
like perfectly seasoned and and and you
know what I mean and then Ron and Nikki
is such a it's such a good metaphor for
how the like the state of the GOP right
now and how fractured and pathetic they
are you know that they their official
debate with these two people these two
suits no one's going to really care
about obviously there'll be some an
audience but like then they have the
former president having his thing and
then vake it's just they're so fractured
um so that's it's going to be
interesting to see that play out it'll
be interesting War gamer 2199 says Jack
bobic and conservatives at large lately
are embracing literal authoritarianism
and in Jack's case praising Franco the
former dictator of Spain because he was
Christian and defender of it well it's a
little bit more complicated than that
Mike covich has been praising Franco as
well the argument is that kamies were
like digging up the corpses of nuns and
parading them and and littering the
streets and things like that the commies
were doing a lot of really really awful
things and so while certainly I'm
learned it enough on Franco to make a
statement there I will point out it's
not so simple to just say Jack and
conservatives are embracing
authoritarianism I would say more so
they're embracing counter communism to a
to to the degree that they think strong
a strong man should be imposed to to
stop them there's a great book called
omage to Catalonia by George Orwell
basically he volunteered to fight on the
side of the Communists in Spain and
while fighting for them with them he
realized he was on the wrong side and
that Revelation that's what leads to
1984 an animal farm the the commies were
doing great evil and Franco stood up
against them and people being afraid of
that or wary of that you know sometimes
it takes a man doing the the strong
thing to fight back against these evil
tyrants if if Tim's Civil War scenario
were to play out where lefties are going
out with guns you're going to want the
federal government out there with guns
against them you're not gonna want to
have to do it with your neighbors it's
not about want it's just about
you know so I watched the new Hunger
Games movie and I got I got to say it's
the prequel I'm really really surprised
actually I know that the the the big
media uh Industries are failing but man
was this movie poorly done it was
terrible yeah it was like a made for
home video movie almost like the
costumes were bad the pacing was bad the
scoring was bad now it's kind of like
there's no character development it's
janky it felt like a fanfiction made for
home sequel like you ever watch Home
Alone 3 oh no oh so Home Alone one and
two is like some burglar engaging
Shenanigans Home Alone 3 is an
international band of terrorists are
trying to steal the missile codes and a
little kid who's not home alone in fact
his mom is there is stopping them in in
a similar way and I'm like wow that's
what it felt like wow but anyway there's
a good point that was made at the end of
the movie uh spoilers I don't care if
you want to see the movie it's a prequel
uh the game master of The Hunger Games
asks uh snow who goes on to become the
president what is the purpose of The
Hunger Games and he says I used to think
that it was punishment for the people
who uh uh you know engaged in war
against us and then he was like now I
realize it's a reminder of what humans
are and what they really are like and so
it's an interesting point the purpose of
The Hunger Games was to show people that
when you're put into the AR he said I
learned the whole world is an arena and
then she and who are you goes I'm the
Victor and that's a that's actually a
really great point that the average
person doesn't understand that that that
fighting in the Hunger Games where you
have people who are friends and then
they're like only one can survive and
they immediately try to kill each other
the only reason we don't have that is
because we have security we have
military we have Security Forces so I'll
tell you this it's not about want in the
event Civil War happens people will cry
and they will beg beg for
authoritarianism they will they will beg
and pray that a strong man would rise up
and just take control because security
and is better than than than Panic fear
and Chaos people would rather have safe
authoritarianism than to be shaking not
knowing when someone's going to kick
their door and kill their family but
this is the point when authoritarianism
gets to the point where you never know
if the government is going to kick your
dor and kill you they collapse that's
what I think a a key contributor to the
fall of the Soviet Union is the
authoritarianism if the authoritarianism
is strictly focused at your communist
enemies like Spain people are going to
cheer but as soon as that government
turns inward and now you fear them
destabilization occurs once again
because nobody feels secure anymore in a
civil war you feel secure When
government forces attack the enemy and
protect your home as soon as that
government starts locking up your
friends and neighbors the security is
gone destabilization happens so right
now for the Franco stuff I think what
they're really saying is they need a
strong man to come and crush the commies
so this is that's a real bad problem
because the the solution to Communism is
not fascism and it's not
authoritarianism it's liberalism it is
the system that we have moved away from
and allowed people to corrupt it is the
restoration of Democrats in America
behaving as if they are liberals and not
the installation of an authoritarianism
from the right that is the exact
opposite of what you want to happen
because what you get is authoritarianism
for the on the right for a little while
but that swing is going to end up with
the Communists rising up and you'll end
up with a state that is
empowered that the Communists just take
over and so all the apparatus that it
needs just like we had with the gwatt
with the global war on terror you've got
this in this gigantic intelligence
apparatus that is literally a global and
it was designed to find one person and
once we found him all they did was start
turning the that same apparatus Inward
and that's why you have the government
literally focusing on Americans as the
enemy right all right thunder clap says
why was it one out of 10 Tim I just
downloaded Twix yesterday and that was
your the first tweet I saw okay so uh I
did a tweet where I broke down all the
restaurants we went to in Alaska and I
gave them scores and one of them got a 1
out of 10 and one of them got a 6 out of
10 and everyone said that it was a dig
at snow City Cafe in I believe it's an
Anchorage um because I gave them one out
of 10 uh I gave all these restaurants
ratings because I was rating the
restaurants that we went to because we
went to like two every day breakfast and
dinner and uh so let's just let's run
through this real quick very simply we
went to Osaka and Barrow dude it is so
cool eating in in Barrow GIC whatever
because it's like a dude's house you
it's a small small place there's no way
to get there other than plane or boat
and so there's a Japanese restaurant and
I got grilled pork belly and uh sushi
sushi was like really fresh I mean
considering like the oceans right there
and uh it was delicious service was
really really great being in the middle
of nowhere and minus it was like minus
20 or likeus 10 I think it was when we
were there uh it was awesome so I gave I
think I gave them like an 8 out of 10 or
a 9 out of 10 top of the world
was a it's a hotel in restaurant guy was
super cool to us we got to sit in a big
Booth brought us coffee we had reindeer
sausage uh Alison got the reindeer
scramble had a great time we went to
Salmon Le's which we were told is the
place to go and the guy who served us
was kind of short with us he spilled my
coffee but gave it to me anyway he made
a hot chocolate for us that one of our
guys didn't want to drink cuz he said it
was like just Brown in water and it
wasn't particularly good um the woman
who was working there was super nice to
us so I kind of feel bad giving him a
six out of 10 but uh we ordered crab
rangon and it was kind of burned and I
was just like look man if it was in New
York I honestly would say don't go there
but it's in Barrow Alaska and you don't
have options is actually pretty good now
I gotta be honest the soup was really
good the pork belly was super good the
guy was a little short with us it's fine
we're not locals but a six out of 10
meaning if you're there you definitely
got to go there we went to uh Anchorage
and as soon as we landed we went to
Sullivan and that was awesome uh we got
there right when they were closing but
they served us anyway super nice people
I got a Caesar salad it was incredible
uh they made me a a french onion soup
with no bread just how I like it uh
other people had the burgers had a great
time and uh one of the guys who worked
there was a big fan and so I was like
wow this is really cool you know I'll
also add that when we went to Barrow I
got recognized several times is just
totally wild to me crazy we were told to
go to snow City Cafe in the morning it's
the place to be so we did and I put my
name on the list and we waited for 15
minutes as they sat several other people
in front of us to where I finally asked
is is there a reason you're seating
other guests in front of us and she said
oh they they other people can text to
get wait you know to come in and I'm
like no no no no there's nobody here
we're standing in the lobby for 15
minutes waiting for a seat there's
nobody here and the list has only my
name on it so one of two things happened
someone texted they wanted to be on the
list and then showed up 15 minutes after
we had already been waiting and they
chose not to seat us because someone had
texted so they were not going to let us
sit down until the person who text I got
it that makes no sense someone walked in
after we had already signed up we're
waiting for 10 minutes and they I'm
standing by this thing they have a sign
up thing and they were like oh are you
in line I'm like oh no no we're signed
up already you can sign up they sign up
minute later the lady walks up and says
right this way and brings them to a seat
a group of four we were a group of four
and I'm like well you
know maybe something happened I'm not
you know but after the third time or
whatever I was just like is there a
reason you're not seating us and they
were just like well people can text in
what's your name and I'm like I'm gonna
go somewhere else because my attitude is
like if they know who I am and they
don't like me and they don't want me to
sit there the last thing I'm Gonna Do Is
Gonna Eat Their Food yeah not interested
yeah for sure and then uh shout out to
borella's base camp in Fairbanks that
was really great we went to gwenny's
instead oh it was amazing uh one of our
guys ordered a uh hot chocolate and it's
this massive bucket of hot chocolate
with a mountain of whipped cream and the
server was walking up with it knowing we
were tourists holding back a smile and
as soon as she puts it down and we all
go whoa she just cracks that big old
smile cuz she knew that that hot
chocolate was going to gwenny's was
awesome and uh good good time and also
shout out to Latitude 65 at Boreal Bas
Camp uh people worked there also were
fans and we got to eat some of the best
food ever wagu it was just really really
amazing she do a timcast Yelp we just
review things but let me just stress
this the reason why I gave snow City
Cafe one out of 10 was not because I'm
mad at them because I don't like them
their food was bad none of that people
were like how could you give them like
did you give this one restaurant a good
rating in your Tweet because and I'm
like because it's not just about the
food like the chairs were comfortable
the people were nice you could have the
worst food in the world but be the
coolest people and have like video games
poker and Magic the Gathering I'm giving
you a 10 out of 10 I'm going be like I
don't want to eat anywhere else but uh
snowy Cafe was just we didn't get to eat
the food we waited a long time they were
uh rude to us when I asked and we ended
up getting nothing out of it so it was
just like in terms of comfortability
zero food quality zero everything zero
weight Time Zero and I give it a one
because looked cool I guess you know it
made me laugh when I saw it I I know the
six out of 10 was there but it was just
like all these good reviews and then
just one one out of 10 like what the
hell I mean every yeah you know it
happens but uh most of we only chose
places that were good oh we went to um
was it Simon and seirs Magic I got to
recommend that place in Anchorage
because if you go there right at Sunset
which is like I don't know 2:30 3:00
p.m. The Horizon is red for like 40
minutes and you can see the mountains in
the water and you get that seat it's
amazing and the food is super good I got
a cocktail that was like in this Dome
thing and they lift it off and Vapors
come out and they waft the vapors at you
yeah what an experience that's awesome
anyway uh Alaska was really really
awesome I I love Alaska thanks everybody
for listening to my why Alaska was so
much fun our next event will be in
Alaska now uh you know oh we actually
were thinking it would be really cool
to do uh show during the
idod and use starlink and see if we can
get starlink to like get us multiple
units and then Bond them to do a live
show from gnome Alaska to make the point
that with starlink is possible because
when we were in ukic there's like
there's self-service there's
AT&T uh and but they use starlink it's
all satellite so for me there's GCI and
AT&T that I think work in N gagic
T-Mobile doesn't work there's I don't
think there's anything else but they
they do have starlink so all the places
got it immediately and I'm like that's
the place to do it wow so gnome is a
town of like 3,000 people to where that
dat rout ends it would be super cool to
go out there for a week and then have
all these starlinks bonded so we're
getting high speeds to do a live show
from Alaska and I'm like it's cool to go
there in the summer and I really want to
go there in the summer when it's
permanent day and we need an excuse to
do it but it would be really cool if I
could be like hey Elon we want to show
how awesome starlink is can we like you
know get something going on that's a
great idea I bet you would I mean just
think about how amazing it's like
starlink can bring you live shows from
the far reaches you know what I mean
from anywhere in the world yeah you
could you could live in the middle you
could live in in the middle of nowhere
in Alaska and do a live show with
starlink yeah and that's crazy because I
mean look we make a lot of money doing
this show if someone in Alaska launched
a political show using starlink and
started generating millions of dollars
imagine how much they could develop in
Alaska that's crazy yeah all right we
got Seth weathers Super Chat he says
just wanted to say sorry not sorry
calendar
Emoji yo calendar gate was wild I love
that Mike cernovich I think it was he
was like the de Republicans are
complaining about a calendar while
Democrats just removed Donald Trump from
the ballot in Maine that's the best way
to conceptualize this whole thing where
the Republicans were fighting over a
calendar while the the Democrats were
removing the leading presidential
candidate from the ballot I I understand
that there are people that have you know
serious religious convictions shut the
hell up with this stupid you're
being stupid and you're screwing
everybody
else and that's probably going to get a
lot of people upset but I'm like on
vacation and I'm seeing these tweets
about like Josie and they're like it's
demonic that she's I'm like what she's
wearing a sundress an apron and she
baked a pie I'm like isn't that as
wholesome as it can be so ridiculous
like no she's showing her legs and so I
tweeted dear God Josie cover those
ankles yeah no one no no one I think any
no no one real cares but whatever people
are pointing out that minus 10 is warm
yeah it was I'm from Chicago so when we
landed I was like I I thought I was
going to have to like wear crazy layers
and I was like ohus 30 I didus 30 was
like okay I'm going to put on some
thermals
but uh Chicago when it was uh 0 degrees
out I'd wear shorts I'm not this is not
an exaggeration in Chicago in winter
it's zero I would put on shorts and
t-shirt and then I would go skate
because the moment I go outside I'm
still warm from inside I start pushing
my board down the street I start
sweating my ass off by the time I get to
my friend's house I'm inside again so I
just be like dude if I wore a coat and
pants I'd be drenched so uh we get to uh
boreal's base camp in Fairbanks and it
was likeus 20 in Fairbanks which but
it's like it's in like a pocket I guess
so we get there we're going to go
snowmobiling they call snow machines and
uh I was kind of worried I'm like it's
going to be we have to bundle up you
know and then I look I'm like it's
feeling fine it was five degrees I was
like ah dude five degrees I took my
jacket off no for real I was like five
no question all right everybody if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
and uh head over to
timcast.net to viewers like you uh I
really do mean it this is how we uh
basically make everything function and
operate while ads do play a role the
main component of how we get everything
done is that people send it become
members and you can join the Discord
server and I will not I cannot stress
enough there is nothing better you you
can name any other membership that you
can buy from any other podcast or
commentator but nothing beats the
Discord server why because you have 247
like-minded individuals and people to
debate and argue with you have a space
to hang out in that keeps the
conversation going forever to your
degree of participation so a lot of
these other guys that we we friends with
they'll be like join our you know
program our membership our club and you
can watch these shows and these special
things and I'm like yeah but you know we
have the members only show we're
launching in a minute or so definitely a
good reason to sign up but the best
reason is that we're building Community
we're building culture and uh we got a
lot of stuff we're working on so let me
just say this when you become a member
at Tim cast.com you're not just buying
access to Discord you are investing in
our cultural Endeavors you're investing
in our efforts to build the C brew
coffee shops and cbw coffee you're
investing in our endeavors to go to the
Iowa caucus so we can do this show let
me let me tell you guys something for us
to do this show in Iowa is likely going
to cost
$100,000 and we just spend the money to
do it we don't have to I could just sit
in this room and we can book whoever we
want and stay here and not travel
anywhere and spend it to zero dollars
but the point is thanks to your support
as members we can go and do a town hall
with awami we can go and cover the
caucus on caucus day and be there live
with a podcast there all thanks to you
guys who are members so for you it may
be it may be just $10 but if a million
people signed up which we certainly
don't have a million subscribers not
like the daily wire we could we could do
exponentially greater and more powerful
things so consider it uh I already said
smash the like button and you can follow
the show at timcast IRL you can follow
me personally at timcast Andrew do want
I shout anything out I got a couple of
show shout outs number one uh when Alex
Jones came back to Twitter uh Jason
calacanis of the all-in podcast was very
upset about it and then he started
saying who could say good things about
Alex Jones well Jason calacanis uh
without Alex Jones there would have been
no president Donald Trump most likely
who saved the first and second amendment
uh with his election of supreme court
with his uh nomination of Supreme Court
Justices so Jason calanis would love to
talk to you on your show you're so upset
that Alex has his Free Speech back talk
to Alex or talk to me and I'm so happy
to announce Alex Jones
game.com fight the New World Order
yourself as Alex Jones defeat the
globalists kill the gay frogs go to
alexjones game.com right now it's the
most fun game of the year people said
game of the year game of the decade not
joking and tomorrow it is live on Steam
so alexjones game.com a couple other
things uh I was at the amfest in Phoenix
and I ran into a legend named Richard
Gage when people would talk about 9/11's
an inside job they'd talk about Alex
Jones and they talk about Richard Gage
who put his career on the line speaking
out as one of the Architects and
Engineers for 911 truth I brought one of
his pamphlets the truth about building
seven what happened Richard Gage
American Legend I hope he gets a chance
to sit in this seat one day and uh
yeah I'm finally back on Twitter Alex
Jones is back on Twitter you can follow
me twitter.com thee Andrew Meyer and uh
I have a gift I didn't get to see Tim at
Christmas but uh I have some Alpha jerky
I have some Alpha jerky for Tim this is
salt and pepper no soy no seed oils no
sugar at Big Club usa.com we are back in
stock your orders are going out Alpha
jerky this is for Tim Merry Christmas
and uh thank you for having me back on
the show Absolutely we'll have you in
the members only so let me try and grab
this jerky right here this is good stuff
because there's nothing in it there's no
BS that's what it's all about that's
right no
BS I am Phil that remains on Twix I'm
Phil that remains official on Instagram
the band is All That Remains you can
listen to us on Spotify Apple music
Pandora Amazon music YouTube you know
the internet Shane I am at Shane Cashman
at all those places online you can find
me I talk about fake clouds a lot and
uh I I appreciate everyone tuning in
happy New Year everyone yeah happy New
Year uh I am happy to be back in the
show it was a lot of news this last week
uh it's been fun to be away but I'm
really happy to be back happy to see you
guys well Happy New Year see you guys on
the after show we'll see you all over at
timcast.net